wird hier erwartet mit einem Redebeitrag
und los geht es aber mit dem
UN-Generalsekretär Antonio guter Resch
wir schalten nach New
yorkelix der Sicherheitsrat befasstet
sich jetzt mit Punkt 2 der Tagesordnung
herzlich denken
Generalsekretär willkommen heißen auch
die Premierminister die Minister und
andere hochrangige Vertreter ihre
Anwesenheit unterschreitet wie wichtig
die heutige Gesprächsrunde ist Herr
Generalsekretär Antonio gute Resch hat
als erster das Wort frau Präsidentin
der
Krieg Russlands in der Ukraine
zeigt kein Anzeichen für ein Nachlassen
in den letzten Monaten haben wir sehr
viel Leid erlebt und die jüngsten
Ergebnisse sind gefährliche und
entfernen uns immer weiter von einer
friedensperspektive wir erleben immer
mehr Horror und gemetze dieser Krieg
verursacht ungeheuren Schaden in der
Ukraine und in der übrigen Welt ein
Atomkrieg war bisher völlig undenkbar
aber heute nehmen einige dieses Wort in
den Mund und die Drohung ist einfach
nicht akzeptabel ich denke es geht darum
dass man sich verpflichtet Atomwaffen
nicht einzusetzen und progressiv zu
entfernen aus dem Waffen Arsenal was
mich beunruhigt sind auch Bestrebungen
sogenannte Referenden in einigen
Regionen der Ukraine zu organisieren die
im Augenblick nicht der Kontrolle der
ukrainischen Regierung unterstehen
wenn ein Staat an anderen Staat Betrug
und der Androhung von Gewalt so ist das
ein Verstoß gegen die Kater der
Vereinten Nationen und gegen das
Völkerrecht frau Präsidentin tausende
von Zivilisten darunter Kinder sind
verletzt oder auch gestorben aufgrund
des russischen
wombatements der Städte fast alle Kinder
in der Ukraine sind traumatisiert durch
diesen Krieg sie sind Gewalt ausgesetzt
oder von ihrer Familie getrennt etwa 14
Millionen Menschen vor allen Dingen
Frauen und Kinder
mhm fliehen und der Winter
Nazi und wenn man sieht dass die Gas und
Strom
Vorräte sich langsam auf brauchen ist
das beunruhigend wir haben eine
finanzielle Krise eine Lebensmittelkrise
und das führt dazu dass tausende und
Millionen noch weiter gefährdet sind und
damit werden Jahre des Fortschritts was
die Entwicklung der Länder anbelangt zu
Nichte gemacht und das nach der
provitkrise und nach
dem was wir alles durch den Klimawandel
schon erleiden die
Kollateralschäden dieses Krieges sehen
wir in sehr vielen
Entwicklungsländern die gerade dabei
waren sich von der Kurve 19 Krise zu
erhoben und die sich der Klimakrise
entgegenstellen und die sind diejenigen
die am ehesten leiden man hat versuche
alles zu tun um das Leiden zu mindern
vor allen Dingen
dadurch dass man in die Ukraine und auch
nach Russland gereist ist dass man
direkt in Gespräche mit Präsident
selenski und Präsident Putin geführt hat
zusammen mit unseren Partner vor Ort ist
es uns gelungen etwa 13 Millionen
Menschen zu unterstützen und es ist von
entscheidender Bedeutung dass
humanitäres Hilfspersonal
ungehindert seine Arbeit erledigen kann
und die
am dringendsten Bedürftigsten Versorgung
kann
Vorsitzender wir haben
berichtet zusammengestellt was die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen anbelangt
standrechtliche Erschießungen
unmenschliches und unwürdiges Verhalten
auch gegen
Kriegsgefangene was sie in Ischium
gesehen haben ist äußerst beunruhigend
all das muss solide untersucht werden
damit die Täter zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden wir brauchen da faire
Gerichtsverfahren und die Familien haben
einen Rechte auf Gerechtigkeit
Entschädigung und Reparation
niemand darf straflos
derartige Verbrechen beginnen und
deshalb spielt der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof da eine große Rolle der
Chef Ankläger hat ja Ermittlungen
angestellt was die Lage in der Ukraine
anbelangt und alle Parteien müssen mit
dem ICC
vollumfänglich zusammenarbeiten frau
Präsidentin die
sondierungsmission nach den Ereignissen
am 29 juli in Ole
diese Mission ist
bereit sofort dahin zu reisen um sich
dort umzuschauen diese
inspektionsmission muss Zugang haben und
ungehindert ihre Arbeit von dem können
frau
Präsidentin die Situation in und um das
AKW saporisha gibt nach wie vor Anlass
zu großer Sorge wir wollen versuchen die
Sicherheit zu des Kraftwerkes zu
gewährleisten ich bedanke mich bei der
IAEA für ihren Einsatz und ihre
Anwesenheit vor Ort stellt natürlich
auch eine Abschreckung da diese
Kraftwerke sollten nur für zivile Zwecke
genutzt werden und Schäden an den
Strukturen ob bewusst oder
unabsichtlich werden zu beruhigenden
Folgen führen und die Welt kann sich
eine nukleare Katastrophe nicht leisten
Frau Vorsitzende mehr als 250
kriegsgefangen wurde gestern zwischen
der Ukraine und Russland ausgetauscht
dass begrüßen wir und ich hoffe dass
diesen Gefangenen Austausch noch weitere
austausche Folgen werden und ich bedanke
mich bei der Regierung der Türkei und
Saudi-Arabien für ihre Rolle als
Vermittler im Juli mit Unterstützung der
türkischen Regierung wurde ein Deal
geschlossen damit wieder Getreide und
Kunstdünger aus drei Häfen der Ukraine
ausgeführt werden können
29 Länder auf drei Kontinenten konnten
inzwischen von diesen Ausfuhren
profitieren drei Schiffe wurden beladen
mit Getreide und gingen Richtung
Afghanistan Jemen und das haben von
Afrika das führt zu Schifffahrt ist dann
wohl verlassen und das fünfte ist auf
dem Weg die globalen
Nahrungsmittelpreise sind dann schafft
zurückgegangen obwohl sie heute immer
noch acht Prozent über dem Niveau des
Vorjahres liegen und es wichtig dass
sich die Märkte noch weiter
stabilisieren die Vereinten Nationen
haben auch an dem morando mit der
Russischen Föderation unterzeichnet die
den vollen Zugang russischer Kunstdünger
darunter auch Stickstoff auf die
globalen Märkte garantieren wir wollen
hier die
schwere Situation auf den Markt für
Kunstdünger stabilisieren Afrika leidet
schon jetzt darunter gelingt es uns
nicht das zu stabilisieren dann wird die
Welt eine große Krise erleben oder sogar
gar nicht mehr genügend Nahrungsmittel
haben insofern müssen Hindernisse für
die Ausführung von russischen
Kunstdünger sofort schnell wie möglich
aus dem Weg geräumt werden die Bauern
müssen diese Kunstdünger so schnell wie
möglich bekommen dann hohe Gaspreise
wirken sich natürlich auch auf die
Produktion von Stickstoffdünger aus auch
das müssen wir lösen Frau Vorsätze die
einzige Möglichkeit um das Leiden in der
Ukraine zu beenden ist ein Ende des
Krieges ich werde mich weiterhin
einsetzen für eine Friedenslösung unter
Achtung des Völkerrechtes und der Kater
der Vereinten Nation ich appelliere an
alle Mitgliedstaaten vor alle an die die
heute hier vertreten sind
noch mehr Anstrengung zu unternehmen
damit sie die Lage nicht weiter
eskaliert und alles zu tun was in ihren
Kräften steht um auf einen dauerhaften
Frieden hinzuwirken vielen Dank
als nächstes hat Herr Karin Kahn das
Wort
exzellen
es ist eine große Ehre
zu dieser runter zu sprechen
der Moment ist gekommen indem wir alle
zusammen durch Tat nicht nur durch Wort
zeigen müssen das Gesetze gelten es ist
wichtig
das klar wird dass das Gesetz die
Menschen verteidigt und schützt das am
meisten brauchen wir haben in der
Ukraine und in vielen anderen Teilen der
Welt gesehen dass die vulnerabi-gruppen
unsere Aufmerksamkeit brauchen
Männer Frauen und Kinder leiden sie
brauchen Sicherheit und sie brauchen das
Gesetz um sie zu schützen und um die
Schuldigen zur Verantwortung zu ziehen
aber dieses Potenzial welches das Gesetz
meine Überzeugung nach
kann nur durch kollektive Handlungen
implementiert werden
wir brauchen die feste Konzentration von
meinem Bereich
vom Gericht aber auch von uns allen wir
müssen überall
Verbrechen zeigen
dass eine Verantwortung gilt jeder der
ein Gewehr in der Hand nimmt jeder der
eine Rakete abschießt muss verstehen
dass das Gesetz lebt dass das Gesetz
nicht schläft und das Verantwortung
wichtig ist
deswegen müssen wir handeln deswegen
müssen wir
Erklärung von Johann
bergaufrechterhalten dass es keine
Verjährung gibt für solche Aktionen und
mal beim Präsident ich bin mir sicher
wenn wir uns auf diese Grundlagen der
monetären Regeln einigen dieser
grundlegenden Verhaltensregeln wird das
Gesetz eine
wichtige und immer wichtiger Rolle
spielen als an Kaffee die Sicherheit in
der Ukraine aber auch in vielen anderen
Teilen der Welt
seit dem Beginn der aktuellen
Entwicklungen in der Ukraine im Februar
wollte ich sicherstellen dass die
Reaktion meiner Abteilung
in den fünf Tagen zwischen dem 25
Februar im zweiten märz als ich meine
ursprüngliche Aussage tätigte und dann
die Ermittlung eröffnete
zielgerichtet
Heike gearbeitet und die 35 Staaten die
das raumstudio da zeichnet haben ein
Drittel der
gesamten Versammlung
die Angelegenheit an das Gericht
verwiesen haben Zeug nicht nur von der
Krise und von den Sorgen sondern auch
von einem Verständnis dass das Gesetz
eine wichtige Rolle zu spielen hat
wir sind
in einem Stadium
vor die Forensik die forensische sehr
detailreicher und manchmal schwieriger
Arbeit durchgeführt wird um Wahrheit von
Lügen zu unterscheiden
um ein Bild davon zu machen was
tatsächlich geschehen ist
die größten Feldeinsatz denn das
internationales hatte und seitdem waren
wir ständig in der UK ja vor Ort
und wir haben angekündigt dass nächste
Woche weitere Mitglieder meiner
Abteilung in die Ukraine reisen werden
die Vorwürfe die im Osten des Landes
gemacht werden zu untersuchen
Zusammenarbeit hat viele Formen neue
Zusammenarbeit mit Staaten mit
internationalen Organisationen und auch
mit der Privatwirtschaft und dieses neue
Modell einer effizienteren Partnerschaft
ein ganz leichtes Modell wird dieser
kollektive Verantwortlichkeit
hoffentlich effektiver machen
aber der Prozess der
Rechenschaft
das festlegen
gemacht wird ist nicht einfach nur
eine theoretische Aufgabe es hilft den
Nebel des Krieges zu durchbrechen hilft
juristischen Umgebung die Wahrheit
aufzuzeigen und wir haben zum Glück
unabhängige Richter und wenn wir unsere
Arbeit erledigt haben werden wir dieser
den unabhängigen Richtern des
internationalen Strafgerichts
präsentieren und sie werden diese sich
anschauen und entscheiden was die
Wahrheit ist und das ist kritisch wenn
wir
das regelbasierte System am Leben
erhalten wollen das ist die einzige
Mission meiner Abteilung der sind keine
politisches Werkzeug wir haben keine
weitere Agenda wir haben
die Verpflichtung die so
wortmächtig im rum statt tut erklärt
wird und der Karte der operei Feind
Nationen
von denen ich heute auftreten darf
durch diese Arbeit wird ein Bild klar
werden
das Bild das sich mir so weiter eröffnet
macht mir Sorgen ich bin dreimal in der
Ukraine gewesen
und ich habe
sehr viel Zerstörung gesehen sehr viel
leiden
dass mich
noch entschlossener macht
alle Verbrechen die unter
die Rechtsprechung dieses Gerichts
fallen aufzuklären und Adam präsent wenn
ich offen sein darf als ich so Mucha kam
und hinter die Andreas gegangen bin
diese Körper
die Leichen waren echt ein Straßen von
euren denkheiten die Zerstörung
in den Straßen in den Schulen der Häuser
der war sehr echt und als ich im
Tierfarm
die dort gelandet sind
sehr klar zu verstehen gegeben was
unsere Brüder und Schwester und Kinder
in Kriegsgebieten zu leiden haben ich
bin tief besorgt über die Worte und die
Informationen die wir erhalten
über
anscheinend bewusster
Beschüsse von zivilen Objekten und auch
die Verschiebung von Bevölkerungsgruppen
aus der Ukraine insbesondere von Kindern
das sind die Prioritäten auf die wir uns
konzentrieren aber unsere gemeinsame
Aufgabe ist es zu zeigen
dass die für jeglicher begangenen
Verbrechen Verantwortlichen wirklicher
in Realtime sie müssen jetzt verstehen
in Echtzeit dass sie ihr Schicksale in
der Hand haben sie haben
die Wahl
und auch die klare Pflicht
proportional zu agieren
und alle möglichen Schritte des
Unternehmen damit Zivilisten und
Zivil Objekte
nicht geschossen werden
fundamentales Menschenrecht
und
sie liegt der uncharte und dem
raumstatue zugrunde
wir sollten heute dich als von Nürnberg
hören
und wenn wir die Versprechen von
Nürnberg
nicht einhalten können sollte es uns
allen zu denken geben
sondern eher zu weiteren Handlungen
angetrieben werden
als eine internationale Organisation als
Mensch
endlich um Gottes Willen erwachsen zu
werden
die Fahne der Legalität
der internationalen Landschaft zu
schieben ich kann heute also nur noch
mal betonen dass ich als strafan Krieger
desintennern den Vereinigten Staaten
anderen internationalen Organisationen
zusammenarbeiten werde um Fälle in der
Ukraine und darüber hinaus untersuchen
meine Verantwortung und die mächtige und
weitere Verantwortlichkeit
die sie haben
erwartet das dass wir die heutigen
Herausforderungen meistern wir müssen
zeigen
dass wir
die Prinzipien der Legalität
durchsetzen werden damit diejenigen die
das verbrauchen die das Gesetz brauchen
davon geschützt werden vielen Dank
und ich möchte
jetzt eine Erklärung im Namen des
französischen
jetzt als ich das Wort ergreife ist sehr
ernst der Aggression die Russland
gestartet hat gegen
einen severinstaat die Ukraine
nichts anderes wollte als frei zu leben
ist eine Verletzung der grundlegenden
Souveränität der Staaten ihrer
territorialen Integrität das sind
Prinzipien die wir alle unterzeichnet
haben die wir hier an diesem tits Tisch
sitzen und die wurden
der Krieger des vom 24 Februar hat auch
zur Zerstörung ziviler Einrichtung
geführte da gab es so viele kriegerische
Handlungen und dafür müssen die
Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden in Wutscher und anderen
Ort wurden fürchterliche Verbrechen
begangen wir stellen immer wieder neue
Fälle von Gräueltaten fest Frankreich
ist der Auffassung das Gerechtigkeit
unser aller Anliegen sein muss es wird
kein Frieden ohne Gerechtigkeit Stadt
geben Gerechtigkeit dass es auch wichtig
für die
Opfer sie verdienen es dass wir ihr
Leiden anerkennen das Leiden eines jeden
Menschen eines jeden
Gerechtigkeit brauchen wir auf
internationaler Ebene und diejenigen die
in diesem kriegt nur an Konflikt sehen
den sage ich wenn alles zulässig ist
jetzt dann wird es auch woanders
zulässig sein und es gibt dann weitere
Fälle von aggressionskriegen
Gerechtigkeit das ist wichtig wir müssen
sicherstellen dass die Täter zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden für die
Verbrechen diese begangen haben
angeordnet haben oder geplant haben es
kann einfach nicht angehen dass
derartige Verbrechen straflos bleiben
wir müssen gegen sie vorgehen und
insofern sind natürlich auch die Richter
oder der Internationale Strafgerichtshof
wurde von 43 Ländern darunter auf
Frankreich angerufen das ist zum ersten
Mal dass diese Länder den
Strafgerichtshof gemeinsam angerufen
haben aber das liegt natürlich auch an
der besonderen Situation ist geht darum
Gerechtigkeit zu üben in der Ukraine und
auch in anderen Ländern und die
französische Gerichtsbarkeit und die
Gerichtsbarkeit einige der hier anwesend
Länder sind auch geforderte
Frankreichs setzt sich ein zusammen mit
vielen anderen Partnern um in all diesen
Ländern darauf hinzuwirken dass
Beweismittel zusammengetragen werden
können westliche Beweise und deshalb hat
Frankreich sofort gehandelt im April
letzten Jahres als die Verbrechen von
Bujar bekannt worden haben wir zwei
Ermittlungs Teams dorthin geschickt sie
waren dort drei Monate um die Fakten zu
sammeln wir hatten auch ein mobiles
DNS-Analyse Labor vor Ort und wir haben
jetzt beschlossen eine weitere
Gruppe vor Ort zu entsenden um die schon
vorhandenen Mittler zu unterstützen ich
denke die Justiz muss sich auch auf
Fakten Gründen können natürlich rufen
wir den Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
an es geht darum dass hier eben auch
Richter und Ermittler bereitgestellt
werden natürlich achten wir die
Unabhängigkeit des ICC und es geht darum
dass alle Länder auch
zusammenarbeiten müssen die Verordnung
von Eurojust wurde ja unter
französischen Vorsitzenden der EU
geändert
das auch deren Vertreter beteiligt
werden können an ermittlungsmissionen
wie zum Beispiel im Fall der Ukraine es
gilt darum gegen die Straflosigkeit
vorzugehen und die internationale
Ordnung zu sichern der russische Krieg
in der Ukraine die
Verletzungen der Menschenrechte
Fälle von Völkermord und Völkermord ist
ja das Verbrechen aller Verbrechen und
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg haben wir ja
uns bemüht eben an internationalen
Strafgerichtshof auch einzurichten der
ICC
wird angerufen um diese falschen
narrative zu untersuchen es ist ja auch
so dass man jetzt Referentin abhalten
will in den besetzten Gebieten
wir gehören zu denen
die natürlich keine Eskalation der
Entwicklung wollen wir Bedenken unsere
Worte aber trotzdem ist es unsere
Pflicht unserer Aufgabe hier auch im
Sicherheitsrat
den Dingen sind zu geben und
abschließend möchte ich einen russischen
Autor zitieren wir müssen öffentlich die
Idee verurteilen dass Menschen Gewalt
gegen andere Menschen verüben können
dürfen nicht
ungestraft davonkommen und in Zukunft
werden wir dann das nur bereuen also
solche nicht ziehen hat diese Zeilen
verfasst und er prangerte ja die
Tausende von Verbrechen der damaligen
UdSSR an und ich denke
seine Worte gelten auch für die
Verbrechen die Russland heute außerhalb
seiner Grenzen begehte wir haben den
Chef Ankläger des internationalen
Strafgerichtshofes gehört er wird ein
Bericht vorlegen und wir schauen uns
dann die Schlussfolgerungen an aber
schon heute müssen wir sagen die
Verantwortlichen müssen
identifiziert werden und vor Gericht
gestellt werden gutes mag Landau an
gerade in den Augen der Opfer aber Sie
müssen die Sicherheit haben dass die
Täter nicht ungestraft
bekommen das schulden wir den Opfern und
ihren Angehörigen
und letztlich geht es auch um unsere
Sicherheit und um universelle Prinzipien
vielen Dank
und jetzt setze ich wieder den Hut als
Vorsitzende Sicherheitsrates auf und
darf Herrn Jonas gavs dorre das Wort
geben dem norwegischen Premierminister
bitteschön
vielen Dank Madame Präsident
vielen Dank
haben wir in den Feinden Nationen
gesehen wie wir als internationaler
globale Gemeinschaft vor
Herausforderungen stehen Krieg
Klimakrise Energie und Sicherheit
Lebensmittel und Sicherheit und wir
sehen wie normale Menschen den höchsten
Preis zahlen und ich glaube es ist
unsere Verantwortung als Mitglieder der
Vereinten Nationen oder besondere der 15
an diesem Tisch
ein Pfad ein Weg zu finden nach vorne
für unsere Bürger für die Menschheit der
Generalsekretär hat das in seiner
Ansprache am Dienstag und noch mal heute
unterstrichen wir haben die Werte die
Grundlagen und sind natürlich in der
neuen Kader festgehalten aber dann
Präsident
legt die regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung fest und dieser
Ordnung wird angegriffen der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine ist eine
grobe Verletzung des internationalen
Rechts auch der unikata der Grundlagen
auf denen dieser Organisation aufgebaut
ist die Souveränität und Gleichheit
aller Menschen und Völker ich habe
gestern aufmerksam die Rede von Putin
mehr angehört mit einer neuen Eskalation
und einer langen Liste von Vorwürfen
Russland Werder vom Westen bedroht und
ja präsent im Namen von Norwegen eine
gewählten mit der dieses Rates einem
europäischen Staat und einem Nachbarn
von Russland lassen Sie mich klar machen
diese Vorwürfe sind einfach nicht wahr
es gibt keine militärische Bedrohung
gegen Russland es gibt überhaupt keinen
legitimen Grund für eine
Massenmobilisierung russischer Truppen
diese Eskalation wird nur zu mehr leiden
für Ukrainer und für Russen führen
Russland muss ich an
die Anweisung des Internationalen
Gerichtshofs halten und seine
Militäroperation in der Ukrainer sofort
anhalten russland hat sich dafür
entschieden diesen Krieg anzufangen
jetzt muss es sich dafür entscheiden
sich zurückzuziehen keiner der
Differenzen zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine kann durch den Militärangriff
gelöscht werden war der Präsident die
Versammlung der Vereinten Nationen hat
uns an die globalen Konsequenzen dieses
Kriegs erinnert steigende Energiepreise
und
lebensmittelunsicherheit betreuen
diejenigen die bereits verletzlich sind
und dazu kommen noch mögliche
nuklearunfälle und der Ukraine die
weitreichende Konsequenzen haben können
die Präsenz russische Kräfte an der eine
Kraftwerke in saporisha
gefährdet die Nuklearsicherheit wir
möchten die Internetseite Agentur für
seine Bemühungen
bedroht auch multilaterale Kooperationen
zu einem Zeitpunkt wenn sie wir sehen
besonders brauchen die schwarzmeere
lebensmittelinitiative ist sehr wichtig
um Getreide an die internationalen
Märkte umbringen wie der Generalsekretär
schon gesagt hat und wir möchten auch
ihm zur aus einem Einsatz dafür
gratulieren und
Norwegen möchte auch seine Unterstützung
dem generalzug der aussprechen wenn
derzeit kommt werden wir als Norwegen
der UN helfen den Frieden aufrecht
erhalten bei der präsent tausende von
Zivilisten und Kieswerk Kinder wurden in
der Ukraine getötet Millionen mussten
aus dem Land flüchten oder wurden von
ihren nächsten getrennt viele wurden in
meinem Land aufgenommen ich hoffe dass
der Tag bald kommt an dem sie sich
wieder in ihr Land begeben können um es
Auflauf zu bauen wieder aufzubauen
Angriffe gegen zivile Infrastruktur sind
inakzeptabel russlandsturzung von
Raketen gegen Schulen Krankenhäuser
Wohnhäuser und aussprechbare
aufgedeckt vom großland kontrollierten
Gebieten und das gibt
besorgniserregende Berichte über
sexuelle Gewalt als Kriegsmittel das
muss aufs schärfster fordert werden wir
vorstellen auch die sogenannten
Referenten in den besetzten Gebieten der
Ukraine
sie laufen international im Recht zu
wieder sie verletzen die un-krater und
sie werden keinerlei Legitimation oder
legale Gültigkeit haben sie werden die
international eine kantengrenzen der
Ukraine nicht verändern das möchte ich
klar sagen oder präsent internationales
Recht ist nicht optional und wie der
chefaktor gesagt hat justizist ist und
politisch alle Vorwürfe müssen
unabhängig aufgeklärt werden und alle
Verantwortlichen zu welchen ich habe
gezogen Norwegen wird die zweite
unterstützen es kann wie
Madame Präsident gesagt hat keine
ungestraftheit geben wir müssen
sicherstellen dass die
Gerechtigkeit erhalten und das Täter zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden durch
nationale oder internationaler
strafgerichter deswegen begrüßen wir die
Ukraine Kommission die der Ausschuss für
Menschenrechte ins Leben gerufen hat und
Norwegen wird das Internet sehr
strafgerichtshofen unterstützen sowohl
im Kontext der Ukraine als auch global
bei deinem Präsident
zum Ende möchte ich sagen
dieser Krieg ist eine Katastrophe für
die Ukraine und die Menschen der Ukraine
großer Konsequenzen haben für
verletzliche
weltweit aber es ist auch sehr schlecht
für Russland für unsere Nachbarn
tausende russische Soldaten wurden in
einem unnötigen und illegalen Krieg in
den Tod geschickt
russische Bürger erhalten zunehmend
immer weniger Menschenrechte und
Grundrechte in einer zunehmend
autoritären Regime wenn das russische
Volk und wir kennen das russische Volk
wenn es sich frei aussuchen könnte würde
es für den Krieg sein wohl nicht
deswegen sind Freiheit und
Menschenrechte
unabdingbar sie fördern Demokratien
Frieden und wir alle müssen Krieg den
Rücken kehren wir müssen die Standards
und Werte der internationalen
Gemeinschaft aufrecht erhalten und die
Grundprinzipien davon ist sind in der
unendlich harter festgehalten der eine
Aggression zu verhindern
es ist sehr wichtig und Norwegen wird
den Rest seiner Zeit hier ein
Sicherheitsrat damit verbringen
diese sinnlosen Kriegs das schnell wie
möglich
zu beenden aber wir stehen auch ein für
das rechte Ukraine sich gegen einen
Angriff gegen Aggression zu schützen
deswegen unterstützen wir die Ukraine
auch bei der Selbstverteidigung wir sind
für internationales Recht für die
Vereinten Nationen die sich für alle
Menschen einsetzen die an diesem Krieg
leiten egal wo Sie sind denn dieser
Aggressionskrieg ist nicht nur ein
Angriff auf die Ukraine sondern auch auf
die Prinzipien und Werte der euren
Krater
die Ukraine geben ihr Leben um diese
universellen Werte zu schützen und ihre
eigene Unabhängigkeit und die Ukraine
kann sich sicher sein dass Norwegen sie
weiter ich unterstützen wird vielen Dank
für ihre Ausführung und jetzt hat
seine
exzellenza
Bonn in der mexikanische Außenministers
Wort vielen Dank Frau Vorsitzende ich
bedanke mich beim UNO-Generalsekretär
Antonio guterisch und bei Karin Kahn dem
Chef Ankläger des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof sehr für ihre
wertvollen Ausführungen
ich spreche im Anschluss an dem
norwegischen Premierminister und weitere
Außenminister sind hier versammelt ich
bedanke mich bei Frankreich bei Ihnen
Frau Ministerin dafür dass sie diese
Debatte veranlasst haben ja geht es um
eine schwerwiegende Verletzung der Kater
der Vereinten Nationen eine Verletzung
des Friedens und der internationalen
Sicherheit
sieben Monate sind vergangen seit dem
Ausbruch des Krieges in der Ukraine mit
vielfältigen folgen und wie bei allen
bewaffneten Konflikten ist es so dass
die Zivilgesellschaft den höchsten Preis
gezahlt hat
Millionen von Menschen mussten fliehen
innerhalb der Ukraine und auch in die
Nachbarländer vor allen Dingen Frauen
und Kinder die Schäden sind enorm seit
Beginn der
Feindseligkeiten hat Mexiko sich immer
wieder für eine diplomatische Lösung
eingesetzt
humanitäre Hilfe ist wichtig aber
natürlich spielen auch politische
Überlegungen die Anwendung des völkeries
einer großen Rolle zusammen mit
Frankreich haben wir dann eine Vorlage
in den
Generalversammlung eingebracht die am 24
März dann auch verabschiedet wurde wir
wiederholen erneut dass die humbionitäre
Hilfe Priorität haben muss wir haben uns
auch dafür eingesetzt soweit uns das
möglich war hier den
Generalsekretär in seiner
Vermittlerrolle zu unterstützen und
zusammen mit Norwegen haben wir eine
Erklärung vorbereitet die am 6 mai
verabschiedet wurde in dieser Erklärung
hat der Sicherheitsrat sich einmal
darauf einigen können eine gemeinsame
Erklärung zu verabschieden der Krieg hat
bisher in norme Menschen Leben gekostet
und enorme Verluste an Material mit sich
gebracht die
Brennstoffpreise sind explodiert und
insofern brauchen wir eine diplomatische
Lösung und alle Beteiligten die
internationale Völkergemeinschaft muss
darauf bestehen dass das Völkerrecht
eingehalten wird das humanitäre
völkerrechte und die Menschenrechte
insgesamt
Rechenschaftslegung ist auch eine
wichtige Säule der Rechtsstaatlichkeit
und der Friedensordnung
insofern meinen wir dass die
Verantwortlichen für die Verbrechen in
der Ukraine vor Gericht gestellt werden
müssen und in diesem Sinn ist es auch
von grundlegender Bedeutung die Arbeit
des Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs zu
unterstützen bei
seinen Ermittlungen und Untersuchungen
der Kriegsverbrechen und wir verfolgen
mit großem Interesse die Fortschritte
bei diesen Ermittlungen es ist
besorgniserregen das hier
gedroht wird mit dem Ansatz der
Atomkraft auch gerade nach den
Ereignissen im Zusammenhang mit dem AKW
saporica wir müssen alles tun um eine
fürchterliche Katastrophe zu verhindern
und insofern unterstützen wir auf die
Bemühungen der IAEA nach ihrer
Inspektionsreise in der Ukraine es geht
darum hier einen sicherheitsperimeter um
das AKW herum einzurichten eine
Sicherheitszone dann
geht es auch darum
die Schiffe wieder durch
das Schwarze Meer hindurch navigieren zu
lassen und das zeigte ja damals auf den
Wert der Diplomatie auch mitten im Krieg
auch da war eine Einigung möglich und
das ist auch von grundlegender Bedeutung
außerdem müssen mehr Kunstdünger wieder
auf die Welt merkt gelangen und wir
wissen da sind schon konkrete Schritte
in diese Richtung unternommen worden und
wir erkennen da die Führungsrolle des
Generalsekretärs der UNO und des
türkischen Präsidenten an frau
Präsidentin von Anfang an war die
Position
meines Landes so dass wir gesagt haben
wir müssen uns auf die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit
stürzen die Karte der Vereinten Nationen
muss eingehalten werden insbesondere
eben friedliche
Konfliktlösung und Verb
der Androhung von Gewalt und das muss
man ganz eindeutig sagen das friedliche
Zusammenleben der Staaten hängt davon ab
dass alle Staaten ohne Ausnahme sich an
diese Regeln halten Artikel 2 der UNO
carta ist davon besonderer Bedeutung es
geht darum dass man keine Gewalt und
Macht anwendet gegen die territoriale
Integrität eines Staates also das sind
grundlegende Garantien die jedes Land
hat ist muss friedlich leben können ohne
bedroht zu werden von einem anderen Land
insofern ist dieser Krieg illegal und
illegitim und der Rat hier hat die
Aufgabe auch zu verhindern dass die
Menschen unter den Folgen des Krieges
Leiden das kann man aber nur auf dem
Wege der Diplomatie und indem man die
politischen Kanäle nutzte
Gleichgültigkeit kann man nicht
akzeptieren und man kann einfach auch
nicht nur die Tatsache beklagen dass
bisher der Sicherheitsrat seine
grundlegende Aufgabe noch nicht hat
erfüllen können die Gründe dafür sind
bekannt fängt nicht alles von uns ab und
es geht darum dass wir jetzt seriös auch
Reformen des Sicherheitsrates in Angriff
nehmen frau Präsidentin Exzellenzen
Mexiko ist der Auffassung dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft jetzt alles
tun muss um den Frieden
herbeizuführen insofern unterstützen wir
natürlich auch die Bemühungen unseres
Präsidenten Obrador der seinerseits
Antonio gutierisch den UNO
Generalsekretär unterstützt ihn auch
aufgefordert hatte ein Komitee für den
Frieden in der Ukrainer einzusetzen und
wenn möglich sollte auch Papst Diskus
und der indische Premierminister Modi
Teil dieses Gremiums sein hier geht es
darum zusätzliche Räume zu schaffen um
Vermittlung zu ermöglichen und Vertrauen
zu stiften so dass wir auf den Weg zu
einem dauerhaften Frieden gelangen die
mexikanische Delegation hat die Absicht
als Unparteiischer gutgläubiger
Akteur dazu beizutragen die Anstrengung
des Generalsekretärs zu unterstützen und
wir wollen dass alle anderen Staaten
natürlich diese Anstrengung auch
unterstützte Generalsekretär hat gesagt
es ist wichtig dass wir jetzt handeln
dass wir uns einsetzen für den Frieden
und der Krieg führt immer zum Abgrund
vielen Dank
ja vielen Dank
das Wort
von Amerika
passt vielen Dank dafür dass sie uns
zusammengerufen haben an diesem zu den
schweren Zeitpunkt
wir brauchen die morale Klarheit
die sieben an und wir möchten Ihnen auch
für Ihren persönlichen Einsatz zeigen um
die schwarzmeerroute zu öffnen und
wieder Getreide aus der Ukraine
exportieren zu lassen Herr Kahn wir
danken Ihnen als Chef Ankläger dafür
dass Sie professionell und unabhängig
die Groll Taten ermitteln die in der
Ukraine von russischen Truppen begangen
werden und führe Zusammenarbeit mit
Unterstützung von ukrainischen
wir hören sehr viel über die
Meinungsunterschiede der Länder in den
Vereinten Nationen aber wir sehen doch
gerade jetzt sehr viel Einigkeit was
Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine angeht
die oberhopter von großen und kleinen
Ländern entwickelten und entwickelnden
im Norden und Süden haben über die
Konsequenzen dieses Krieges gesprochen
und über den Notwendigkeit ins beenden
und Sie bitten uns alle die über ein
harter und seinen Grundprinzipien
inklusive der Souveränität der Ritualen
die Kritik und Menschenrechte zu achten
selbst viele Nationen die enge
Beziehungen zu Russland unterhalten
haben wir nördlichkeit in der
Öffentlichkeit gesagt dass sie Fragen
und Sorgen haben in Bezug auf präsent
Potenz Invasion allerdings hat er seinen
Kurs nicht geändert
er hat in
weiter ausgebaut statt den Krieg zu
beenden seine Truppen nicht
zurückzuziehen sondern 300.000
zusätzliche
Soldaten einzuberufen
die Eskalation voranzutreiben durch die
Drohung von Nuklearwaffen keine
diplomatische Lösung zu suchen sondern
so eine Lösung unmöglich zu machen indem
er noch mehr
ukrainisches Gebiet durch
als Referenden
und das zeigt was er von der
internationalen Ordnung hält dieser
internationale Ordnung die wir hier
schützen sollen wird vor unseren Augen
mit Füßen getreten wir können und wir
werden präsent Putin nicht davonkommen
lassen
die Verteidigung der Okra ukrainischen
Souveränität und der ritterallen
Integrität ist nicht nur der Schutz der
Rechte eines Landes so wichtig dieses
Recht auch ist es muss zeigen dass kein
Land in Grenzen gewaltsam ändern kann
wenn wir dieses Prinzip nicht
aufrechterhalten wenn der Kreml damit so
augenscheinlich bricht
wird jedes Land gefährdet sein die Welt
wird weniger friedlich weniger sicher
sein wir sehen wie dieser Welt aussieht
in den Gebieten der Ukraine die von
russischen Truppen kontrolliert werden
war immer der russische Flut
zurückgeht sehen wir was sie zurücklässt
ich konnte das Einsehen als ich vor
einigen Wochen nach erpinnen gereist bin
und mich mit ukrainischen im Mitteln
getroffen habe die dort
Verbrechen gegen die Menschenrechte
untersuchen ich habe die riesigen Löcher
gesehen den Wohnhäusern von russischen
Beschuss hinterlassen worden bestenfalls
zufällig stundenfalls absichtlich
und während wir hier sitzen sammeln
ukrainische Mittler weiterhin Körper bei
Issum der ukrainischen Stadt ist von
Russland besetzt war bevor die
keine
Gegenangriff siehe wieder rausgejagt hat
viele der hunderte von deinem Körper
zeigen Spuren
von Folter inklusive einem Körper mit
gebrochenen Armen und einem Seil umsalz
ein Mann beschreibt wie er vier Tage
lang von russischen Truppen gefoltert
wurde während der er ständig
Elektroschocks erhalten hat und ich
zitiere ich geschlagen wurde bis ich
nichts mehr fühlen konnte
das sind keine Handlungen von außer
Kontrolle geratenen Truppen das ist ein
klares Muster das wir von der russischen
Armee sehen und deswegen unterstützen
wir der
nationalen und internationalen
Bemühungen Beweise für die russischen
Verbrechen in der Ukraine zu finden wir
müssen die Verantwortlichen zurechta
deswegen helfen auch mehr als 40 Länder
den Ukrainern sich selbst zu verteidigen
ein Recht das in Artikel 1 der euren
Theater festgestellt ist
je mehr Probleme Russland
auf
im im Krieg erleiden desto mehr Schaden
richten sie an den ukrainischen Zwillen
Infrastruktur an Brücken Krankenhäuser
Kraftwerke und das ist eine klare
Verletzung des internationalen
humanitären rechts diese Woche hat
präsent Putin gesagt dass Russland nicht
zögern würde
ich zitiere alle verfügbaren
Waffensystemen zu benutzen wenn seine
territorelle Integrität bedroht wird
diese Bedrohung macht umso mehr Sorgen
wenn wir bedenken dass Russland große
Gebiete der Ukraine möchte wenn dies der
Fall ist wird präsent Putin vermutlich
alle ukrainischen Bemühungen in diese
Gebiete zu befreien als Angriff auf
russisches Gebiet betrachten und das von
einem Land das im Januar diesen Landes
hier
andere ständigen Mitglieder des neuen
Sicherheitsrates
zusammen eine Erklärung unterschrieben
hat in der stand ich zitiere eine klar
kriegt kann nie gewonnen werden und darf
nie stattfinden
das ist eine weitere Verpflichtung der
Russland eingehalten nicht eingehalten
hat und deswegen sollte niemand glauben
was Russland heute sagt jedes Mitglied
dieses Rates muss deutlich sagen dass
diese verantwortungslosen nuklear
Drohungen sofort aufhören müssen
der russischen Bemühungen noch mehr
ukrainisches Gebiet zwar nichts hier
sind eine gefährliche Eskalation sowie
eine Absage an die Diplomatie und es ist
immer mehr alle armierend denn der
russischen Kräfte
Straftaten Gräueltaten in den Gebieten
die sie kontrollieren
Sie deportieren Ukraine
sie fahren Russen in diese Gebiete und
dann halten sie refender referente ab
über den beitrittshowschen Föderation
genauso ist das in der Krim passiert
genauso wie bei der Creme ist das
wichtig dass jedes Mitglied dieses Rates
und auch jedes Mitglied der Feind
Nationen diese
vorgeblichen Referenten nicht akzeptiert
und sagt das alles was innerhalb der
grenznokrain ist auch innerhalb dieser
Grenzen bleiben wird und keine Ansagen
von Russland
reines recht ändern können sich zu
verteidigen
auch diesen Rat und das gesamte
UN-System davon ab die ernsten Fragen
abzuarbeiten auf die wir uns eigentlich
konzentrieren sollten zum Beispiel die
Klimakatastrophe durch zu verhindern
wir ziehen die Dutzende von Millionen
Menschen zu helfen die Kinder leiden
eine nachhaltige
Wirtschaft simplementieren und eine
langfristige Energiesicherheit das alles
beeinflusst das Leben der Bürger die wir
hier vertreten und die
von uns wollen dass wir Ihnen Ergebnisse
bringen die meisten neuen
Mitgliedsstaaten wollen an diesen
Problemen zusammenarbeiten und ihre
Handlungen zeigen das
aber
mehr als 100 Länder haben eine Roadmap
unterschrieben
Lebensmittel an diejenigen die sie am
meisten brauchen aber Russland hat
monatelang die exporter von ukrainischem
Weizen
an die Welt blockiert ist die
Vereinigten Staaten und die Türkei ein
Deal erreicht haben und Russland
bombardiert weiterhin ukrainische
Getreidespeicher und vermiet die
ukrainischen Getreidefelder und
Regierungen weltweit arbeiten mit
internationalen Organisationen und der
Privatsektor zusammen mit Stiftungen um
diese Pandemie zu beenden und
sicherzustellen dass wir die nächste
bekämpfen können und derzeit verbreitet
Russland Fehlinformationen und falsche
Information
über von der
Weltgesundheit aus Organisationen zu
lassen Impfungen
die Wahrheit ist niemand von uns hat
diesen Krieg gewollt weder die Ukraine
die wusste was er sie kosten würde noch
die feindlichen Staaten die gewarnt
haben dass der Krieg kommen würde und
daraufhin gearbeitet haben es ihn zu
verhindern
noch die überwiegende Mehrheit der
vereinigten der Mitgliedstaaten der
Vereinigten Nationen noch unsere Völker
sie fühlen die Konsequenzen des Krieges
die lebensmittelunsicherheit die hohen
Energiepreise noch die russischen Mütter
und Väter deren Eltern rausgeschickt
werden um in diesem Krieg zu kämpfen und
zu sterben oder die russischen Bürger
die weiterhin ihre Freiheit riskieren um
gegen diesen Krieg zu protestieren auch
diejenigen die auf die Straßen von
Moskau gekommen sind nach der
Ankündigung von präsent Putin und gesagt
haben lasst unser Kinder am Leben
und wir müssen uns fragen
wer hat dieser Aggression
gegen die Ukraine das Leben auch nur
eines russischen Bürgers verbessert ein
Mann hat sich für diesen Krieg
entschieden ein Mann kann ihn beenden
denn wenn Russland aufhört zu kämpfen
würde Krieg vorbei sein wenn die Ukraine
aufhört zu kämpfen wer die Ukraine
vorbei sein
deswegen werden wir auch weiterhin die
Ukrainer unterstützen
in der Selbstverteidigung und wir werden
auch bei einer diplomatischen Lösung
einen gerechten Lösung unterstützen wir
präsenzellensky wiederholt gesagt hat
das ist der einzige Möglichkeit diesen
Krieg zu beenden Diplomatie aber
Diplomatie darf nicht
benutzt werden um der Ukraine eine
Lösung aufzuzwingen die die unikata
verletzt
seine Wahl
nun müssen
all unsere Länder
Entscheidungen treffen
wir müssen präsent Putin sagen dass er
den Schrecken werden soll wenn ihr
angefangen hat dass er aufhören soll
seine Interessen über die Interessen der
Restes der Welt auch seine eigenen
Menschen zu stellen
dieses diesen Rat zu ignorieren und
alles wofür steht wir die Menschen der
Vereinigten Nationen so beginnt die
Karte der Vereinigten Nationen vergessen
wir nicht dass wir die Menschen wir die
Völker immer noch das Schicksal dieser
Institution und unserer Welt bestimmt
kennen
die Einsätze der Einsatz ist klar wir
haben die Wahl machen wir die richtige
Wahl für die Welt in der wir leben
wollen in der unsere Leute leben wollen
und diese verdienen vielen Dank
für seinen Vortrag nun bitte erbardier
Außenminister Chinas
Generalsekretär
ich danke Herrn Außenminister kolonna
dass er diese heutige Sitzung einberufen
hat
und danke auch generell
uterisch für sein Briefing zu Beginn
die Position Chinas zur Ukraine ist klar
und konsistent
präsentativen Ping hat darauf
hingewiesen die Souveränität die
tirtuelle Integrität aller Staaten ist
zu achten
die Zielsetzungen und Grundsätze der
uno-karter sind einzuhalten die
Sicherheitsbedenken aller Staaten sind
ernst zu nehmen und alle beim
Vorbedingungen wir müssen den Dialog
anstreben oder ein Ergebnis
vorwegzunehmen
vertretbare Anliegen sind die
Lieferungen aufzunehmen und sinnvolle
Optionen sind auf den Tisch zu legen
damit es letztlich nach den Ergebnissen
auch zum Frieden kommen kann wir müssen
gemeinsam auf eine d-eskalation
hinarbeiten die Beteiligten sollten sich
zurückhalten und eine Steigerung der
Spannungen vermeiden die
Völkergemeinschaft muss eine
konstruktive Rolle spielen und dazu
beizutragen zu deeskalieren und die
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen für eine
politische Regelung
wenn es dann um die Sicherheit von
kernenergieanlagen geht so gibt es da
keinen Platz für Trial and Error man
darf nicht riskieren die Risiken müssen
ins Auge gefasst werden wie unterstützen
die IAA mit ihren Positionen und ihrer
positiven Rolle
drittens müssen wir ehrlich die
humanitäre Lage ins Auge nehmen es kommt
darauf an dass wir die internationale
humanitären Rechtsvorschriften einhalten
ohne Angriffe auf Zivilisten zivile
Einrichtungen und dergleichen müssen
auch die Pferde zivilen Opfer reduzieren
Verstöße gegen das humanitäre
Völkerrecht sind zu verfolgen und müssen
auf der Grundlage der tatsächlichen
Gegebenheiten beurteilt werden ohne
Politisierung die Völkergemeinschaft
muss die humanitären Einrichtung der
Vereinten Nationen unterstützen und der
Förderung der Neutralität und der
Gerechtigkeit und Billigkeit und die
unterstützen die in der Ukraine die
Nachbarländern betroffen sind
viertens müssen wir darauf achten dass
Energie Lieferanten und Verbraucher
zusammenarbeiten müssen
damit der weltweite Energiemarkt stabil
bleiben kann
wir unterstützen den Generalsekretär bei
Bemühungen um die Förderung der Ausfuhr
russischen und ukrainischen Getreides
jeder hat
die Initiative für weltweite
Lebensmittelsicherheit unterstützt mit
Beiträgen aller Staaten kein Staat
sollte hier einseitige
Sanktion betreiben den Preis würden die
entwicklungsde der zahlen müssen frau
Präsidentin der Sicherheitsrat als
Kernbestandteil des internationalen
Sicherheitsmechanismus muss die
Grundsätze der Objektivität unter
Unparteilichkeit bei der Ukraine
einhalten den richtigen Kurs verfolgen
hin zu einem Waffenstillstand und
Friedensverhandlungen und
Vermittlungsmöglichkeiten anbieten mit
dem Bestreben eine Lösung zu erreichen
wir müssen positive Energien einsetzen
für Frieden und Versöhnung und
konstruktive und verantwortungsbewusste
Maßnahmen für eine politische Regelung
ergreifen die ukraine-krise hängt eng
zusammen mit der weltweiten Situation
hier schwieriger die Lage ist desto
wichtiger ist es der einzubleiben und
nach Lösungen zu streben wir müssen
koordiniert arbeiten um eine auf den
Vereinten Nationen aufbauende
Weltsituation herbeizuführen und der
Einhaltung international Normen unter
Beachtung der Grundsätze und
Vorschriften der uno-kärter unter
Berücksichtigung der berechtigten
Anliegen aller Seiten macht Politik ist
zu vermeiden und jede Form des heißen
Krieges oder des sogenannten kalten
Krieges in diesem Fall vermeiden es geht
um eine umfassende kooperative
Sicherheitspolitik die Streben
gemeinsame Grundlagen ahnt wir müssen an
der verstehen und unermüdlich daran
arbeiten die Sicherheit in Europa und
den Frieden in der Welt herzustellen
danke
für seine Rede und
über haben jetzt haben wir den
albanischen Außenminister
frau Präsidentin ich darf mich den
Kolleginnen anschließen und Kollegen und
mich bedanken für die Organisation
das Thema das wir besprochen haben ist
ja ununterbrechung auf der Agenda und
das insbesondere angesichts der letzten
Eskalation des Kreml sich begrüße auch
die Entscheidung der französischen
Präsidentschaft weiterhin den Fokus zu
legen auf das hauptaugenmerzlingen auf
die Rechenschaft die Russland abverlangt
werden muss und
ich darf auch noch mal zurückkommen auf
das april treffen dass wir organisiert
haben in albinien ich danke Herrn kann
auch für seine Informationen und auch
dann für seine Bemühungen hier in der
Ukraine für gerechtigtheit zu sorgen
Damen und Herren meine Damen und Herren
Russland ein ständiges Mitglied des
UNO-Sicherheitsrates hat einen
unrechtmäßigen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
begonnen und wie wir schon öfter gesagt
haben in der Vereinten Nationen die
Aktion der Russen sind eine
skrupellose Verletzung der Prinzipien
der Kater der Vereinten Nationen deshalb
hat auch der Internationale Gerichtshof
Russland aufgefordert seine
militär-operation in der Ukraine
einzustellen die Weisungen sind
natürlich bindend für alle aber Russland
hat beschlossen diese
Anweisungen zu ignorieren die Grundsätze
auf denen die
UNO gründet
ist der Respekt vor den internationalen
Gesetzen und
Absprachen trotz der Schwierigkeiten und
Herausforderungen haben wir tatsächlich
in der Vergangenheit
die Rechtsstaatlichkeit auf
international internationaler Ebene
weiter gefördert und wer ist es ganz
klar dass niemand über dem Gesetz stehen
kann wir hoffen dass die Welt oder wie
oft denn dass die Welt nie wieder in die
Vergangenheit die düstere zurückfallen
würde aber dieser flagrante Versuch
Russlands Teile des ukrainischen
Territoriums zu erobern sind tatsächlich
eine Erinnerung an die Zeiten des
staatlichen Stalinismus und des
Narzissmus das was heute in der Ukraine
passiert erinnert uns an diese düstere
Vergangenheit und die
Gruppen die tatsächlich
die Fakten vor Ort feststellen sollen
haben Fest haben die Kriminalität
der Russen gegen die lokale Bevölkerung
festgehalten unschuldige Männer Frauen
und Kinder in der Ukraine aber auch
Zehntausende von russischen Soldaten
haben für Vladimir Putins
Krieg mit dem Leben bezahlt
Millionen weltweit leiden an Hunger
aufgrund dieses Krieges von Wladimir
Putin und wir
verurteilen natürlich auch die
teilmobilisierung in Russland wir
verurteilen die Ableitung von vier
Referenden in den von Russen besetzten
ukrainischen gebetsgebieten und wir
verurteilen auch die Änderung der
Verwendung der des Einsatzes von
Massenvernichtungswaffen die Verletzung
der territorialen
Integrität der Ukraine ist eine
ernsthafte Verletzung der Kater der
Vereinten Nationen wir unterstützen die
ukrainische Unabhängigkeit die
Souveränität des Landes und wir fordern
Russland jetzt sich bedingungslos mit
allen militärischen Truppen und
sämtliche militärischen Material vom
Territorium der Ukraine zurückzuziehen
und dies hinter die international
vereinbarten Grenzen wir müssen deshalb
unsere Anstrengungen noch erhöhen und
die Ukraine unterstützen und wir müssen
dafür wir müssen garantieren dass
Russland voll und ganz Verantwortung
gezogen wird zur Rechenschaft gezogen
wird es geht hier nicht nur um Justiz
sondern es geht auch um die Verhinderung
zukünftiger Grausamkeiten
wir dürfen jetzt nicht
wir müssen jetzt auf jeden Fall Russland
auch zu Verantwortung ziehen danke schön
danke
ich gebe nun das Wort
dem
Außenminister Irlands Herr seinem Cover
Name
stand ich auf dem Deck eines Frachters
im Hafen von Odessa und sah wie 46.000
Tonnen Getreide verladen wurden
Ziel Bangladesch
selben Tag war die gesamte Getreidemenge
sie aus ukrainischen Häfen über die
Schwarzmeer Getreide Initiative in
exportiert worden waren bei drei
Millionen Tonnen angelangt
das ohne Personal in Odessa sprach davon
man wollte in einem Monat vier Millionen
Tonnen beisammen haben als Exportmenge
das ist schon deutlich gesagt worden es
geht bei diesen Schiffen nicht nur um
den Transport von Getreide sondern auch
um die seltene Ware Hoffnung
wir müssen daran denken wie mächtig der
Multilateralismus sein kann inmitten von
Konflikten die Vereinten Nationen und
die türkische Regierung haben in dieser
Phase eine Abmachung ausgehandelt den
dringend benötigten Weizen aus der
Ukraine auf die Welt merkte zu schaffen
das erfolgte über ein Dialog über die
Nutzung des Systems und der Strukturen
der Normen und Institutionen die wir mit
großen Mühen in Jahrzehnten aufgebaut
haben um Differenzen beizulegen Lösungen
zu finden und unseren Bürgern das
erwartete zu liefern das sind die
Grundsätze die Institutionen die wir
alle hier um den Tisch herum feierlich
zu wahren versprochen haben frau
Präsidentin dann noch ein anderer Aspekt
der Hoffnung im Januar dieses Jahres
hatten die Führer der fünf
Kernwaffenstaaten einschließlich
Russland erklärt ein nukleakrieg könne
nicht gewonnen werden und dürfe in die
stattfinden diese fünf politischen
Führer einschließlich Präsident Putin
hatten sich verpflichtet Konfrontation
zu vermeiden die Verlässlichkeit und
Vorhersagbarkeit zu verbessern das
Vertrauen durch Maßnahmen zu stärken und
den Dialog im gegenseitigen im
gegenseitiger Achtung zu betreiben sechs
Wochen später begann Russland dann mit
einem nicht gerechtfertigten Überfall
auf die Ukraine ein weiterer souveräner
mitgliedstatt für Ordination ist
angegriffen worden und in dieser Woche
tun hat Präsident Putin erneut Drohungen
ausgestoßen und hat den Einsatz von
Kernwaffen droht hier muss folgendes
völlig klar sein der russische Überfall
auf die Ukraine ist die Antithese der
Grundsätze der Karte der Vereinten
Nationen das ist eine schwerwiegende
Verletzung des Völkerrechts ein Versuch
international anerkannte Grenzen mit
Gewalt zu ändern
und kein Schein Referendum kann an
dieser Grundtatsache etwas ändern es
darf nicht hingenommen werden das ist so
weitergeht wenn wir Russland nicht zur
Rechenschaft ziehen können dann schicken
wir ein Signal an große mächtiges Garten
das sie ihre Nachbarn ungestraft
überfallen dürfen und jede Nation auf
Erden sollte daran denken und dies zur
Kenntnis nehmen deshalb hat Irland
gestern eine Erklärung vorgelegt
die dem Internationalen Gerichtshof in
der Rechtssache Ukraine gegen Russland
vorgelegt deswegen schalten wir uns in
dieses Verfahren vor dem Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte ein
deswegen unterstützen wir Maßnahmen bei
der OECD im Europarat in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen und bei Menschenrechtsrat
Russland muss zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden für das was es tut
mit 42 anderen Vertragsparteien am
Internationale Strafgerichtshof haben
wir die Lage der Ukraine dem hier heute
Anwesenden Staatsanwalt vorgelegt die
Ukraine muss unterstützt werden bei
ihren Bestrebungen Entschädigung zu
erhalten und wir werden deshalb mit der
Ukraine und anderen Partner
zusammenarbeiten um zu prüfen wie die
Russland zur Rechenschaft ziehen können
für dieses Verbrechen des Überfalls der
Aggression
deshalb aber auch muss dieser Rat
Kollektiv darüber nachdenken wie er
handeln soll um die Grundsätze und
Zielsetzung der uno-karter selbst
schützen kann kein einziger Staat wie
groß oder wir mächtig auch immer darf
die Möglichkeit haben die Anwendung des
Völkerrechts für eigene Ziele umzubieten
frau Präsidentin ich habe im April hier
im Rat gesagt dass ohne
Rechenschaftspflicht keine Hoffnung auf
einen nachhaltigen Frieden bestehen kann
nicht in der Ukraine nirgendwo sonst und
das will ich heute wiederholen
ich möchte auch daran erinnern was ich
im April schon sagte die erschreckenden
Belege in Butcher das russische Truppen
das humanitäre Völkerrecht missachtet
haben da ist nichts erfunden worden die
Leichen die ich dort gesehen habe
erzählen ihre eigene Geschichte erzählen
die Wahrheit fünf Monate später werden
weitere Massengräber in Issum gefunden
und in anderen Gebieten die bis vor
kurzem russisch besetzt waren
Angriffe russischer Streitkräfte auf
Zivilisten und die ziviler Infrastruktur
sind seitdem weiter verstärkt worden die
verheerenden Folgen von
sprengstoffeinsätzen in besiedelten
Gebieten sind deutlich zu erkennen
Zehntausende von Wohnungen
Krankenhäusern und Schulen sind zerstört
worden
deshalb unterstützte ich die Initiative
dass alle Staaten die politische
Erklärung mittragen sollen über den
Lichteinsatz von Sprengstoffen in
besiedelten Gebieten wir werden november
in Dublin darüber sprechen
frau Präsidentin Millionen von
Zivilisten in der Ukraine und anderswo
sind potentiell gefährdet durch die
russische Besetzung des Kernkraftwerks
saporisia ich möchte die Forderung von
letzter Woche wiederholen letzte Woche
hat der Gouverneursrat der IAA gefordert
das Russland sofort alle Maßnahmen gegen
das geldkraftwerk Seper einstellen muss
die ukrainischen Behörden müssen wieder
in die volle Kontrolle über die
Kernkraftwerke erhalten wir können nun
wirklich keinen nuklearen Unfall zur
Zeit gebrauchen und sonst auch nicht
diese Konflikt wird irgendwann zu Ende
kommen unsere kollektive Verantwortung
für die Karte der Vereinten Nationen für
die friedliche Streitbeilegung für die
Aufrechterhaltung des Weltfriedens und
der inneren Sicherheit verlangen dass
dies möglichst bald geschehen soll der
Weg hin zum Frieden ist klar
vorgezeichnet Staaten die bewusst
entschieden haben diesen Konflikt zu
Beginn müssen jetzt auch entscheiden ihn
zu beenden Russland muss seine
Streitkräfte vom souveränen Gebiet
anderer UN-Mitgliedstaaten zurückziehen
Russland muss Rechenschaft ablegen vor
internationalen Gremien für das was es
getan hat wir haben dafür eigene Gremien
geschaffen
es geht nicht nur um die Ukraine und die
Zukunft des Landes es geht um die
gesamten ohne Mitgliedstaaten um alle
unsere Länder wenn wir die russischen
Maßnahmen nicht zurückweisen
in eindeutiger und missverständlicher
Form dann lassen wir zu dass die Welt
von der Gewalt bestimmt wird und nicht
vom Dialog und ich die Anwendung des
Völkerrechts frau Präsidentin der
Sicherheitsrat muss sich an die Spitze
der Bewegung setzen
zunächst los müssen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre für Ihren
Vortrag jetzt habe ich das Wort erteilen
dem Herrn sobram
maniam yay changar dem Außenminister
Indiens ich dachte zu allererste der
französischen Präsidentschaft für die
Organisation dieser Sitzung ganz
herzlich danken und ich danke auch dem
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
Antonio gutärisch und ich nehme die
die Anmerkungen von kmkern dem Chef
Ankläger des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshofs ebenfalls auch zur
Kenntnis wir sind jetzt daran darf ich
erinnern es Indien ist nicht co-signatur
der römischen Konvention die Entwicklung
dieses Konfliktes zwischen Russland und
der Ukraine ist erfüllt die gesamte
Völkergemeinschaft mit großer Sorge und
die Zukunft sieht in der Tat noch sehr
viel beunruhigender aus das Thema der
Atomwaffen ist besonders beängstigend in
einer globalisierten Welt es sind die
Auswirkungen eines solchen Konfliktes in
den auch entferntesten Regionen der Welt
zu spüren wir haben alle die Folgen
schon an unserem eigenen Leib erfahren
aufgrund der des Mangels an
Getreide und Düngemitteln deshalb
bestehen gute Gründe sich hier Sorgen zu
machen
die
Welt
empfindet oder fühlt diese Folgen sehr
schmerzhaft und wir dürfen keine
Maßnahmen treffen die jetzt die
Weltwirtschaft noch weiter in den
Abgrund stürzt und trotz der starken
Rhetorik brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
jetzt sofort eine Einstellung sämtlicher
Feindseligkeiten und die Rückkehr zur
Diplomatie und zu ver wie Herr
premiermesser modri gesagt hat kann das
darf das kein ewiger Krieg sein wir
Stellen von unserer Seite aus humanitäre
Hilfe für die Ukraine zur Verfügung und
auch Wirtschaftshilfen für Nationen die
jetzt unter besonderem Stress stehen
lassen Sie mich auf das Thema der
heutigen Sitzung zurückkommen selbst in
Konfliktsituationen darf es keine
Rechtfertigung geben für die Verletzung
von Menschenrechten oder internationalen
Recht und Gesetz wenn solche aktive
auftauchen oder vorkommen dann müssen
Sie unabhängig und objektiv untersucht
werden das ist unsere Position die wir
zu den goldtaten in Butcher eingenommen
haben und das sagen wir heute noch
einmal erneut wir
fordern und unterstützen sämtliche
Forderungen einer nach einer
unabhängigen Untersuchung der Kampf
gegen Straflosigkeit ist tatsächlich
essentiell für internationales Recht und
internationale Gerechtigkeit der
Sicherheits muss eine eindeutige
Botschaft in dieser Hinsicht auch
aussenden Politik sollte
Politiker sollte nie und nimmer es
irgendjemandem erlauben sich der
internationalen
Verantwortung und Rechenschaft zu
entziehen das haben wir in dieser in
dieser Kammer schon des öfteren gesagt
insbesondere wenn es zu den Sanktionen
kommt
die furchtbaren Angriffe die bei hellem
Tageslicht erfolgen dürfen nicht
straflos bleiben und dieses Signal
müssen wir aussen es darf keine
Straflosigkeit geben wir müssen da auch
konsequent bleiben wenn wir glaubwürdig
bleiben wollen noch einmal lassen Sie
mich auch frau Präsidentin unterstützen
dass der Konflikt jetzt beendet werden
muss und dass beide Parteien wieder in
den Verhandlungstisch zurückkommen
müssen dieser hat hier ist das beste
zeitgenössische Beispiel für Diplomatie
und wir müssen deshalb auch Rolle
erfüllen unseren Zweck erfüllen die
Weltordnung für die wir alle stehen
basiert auf internationale Recht und
Gesetz und auf der Unabhängigkeit der
Nationen und diese Grundsätze müssen
selbstverständlich auch weiterhin unter
aufrechterhalten werden herzlichen Dank
Frau Präsidentin
schon
ich bin bedanke mich für seine Existenz
für seine Ausführungen
und jetzt hat Herr Michael Musa Adamo
der Außenminister gabunst das Wort
Präsidentin dafür dass sie Initiative
geworden sind ich denke es geht hier um
die Lage in der Ukraine und es geht
darum hier Lösungen zu finden zu einer
Zeit wo die Welt am Wendepunkt steht ich
bedanke mich beim Generalsekretär für
seine neuesten Informationen zur Lage in
der Ukraine und ich darf mich auch bei
einem Chef Ankläger des ICD Herr Karin
Kahn herzlich bedanken herr Präsident
die Menschheit verliert ihre Richtschnur
wann immer Krieg und Gräueltaten
vorherrschen der Krieg ist für uns eine
Herausforderung in mehrfacher Hinsicht
10.000 sind Verletzungen gestorben
Städte liegen in Ruinen Menschen sind
verletzte
Desinformation und eine Neufassung der
Realität
die Herausforderung des Einsatzes von
Atomwaffen und deren fürchterlichen
Konsequenzen die Sorge um die
Nahrungsmitteln Sicherheit weltweit
angesichts dieser großen
Herausforderungen richten sich die Augen
der Völker der Welt auf diesen Rat es
geht darum dass man die Hindernisse auf
dem Weg zufrieden und international als
Sicherheit aus dem Wege und Männer und
Frauen und Kinder haben Angst vor einer
neuen Atomkatastrophe sie fragen wann
endet der Krieg in der Ukraine und den
Schulden wir eine antworten wir müssen
der Verantwortung gerecht werden die
Kater der Vereinten Nationen die von den
Völkern der Welt unterzeichnet wurde
sollte Richtschnur sein die Hoffnung der
Menschen richten um sich auf sie wir
sind gegen den Krieg wir sind gegen
Hassreden wir sind gegen empörende
Rhetorik gegen Aggression und Gefährdung
des Friedens frau Präsidentin mein Land
stellt mit Interesse
fester dass der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof für Untersuchungen
eingeleitet hatte um Beweismittel in der
Ukraine zusammenzutragen und die Fakten
zusammen Angesicht der Anschuldigen von
Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit
Massentötungen
erzwungene Deportation und die
Gerechtigkeit muss obwalten der
Gerichtshof muss unabhängig entscheiden
und alle internationalen Mechanismen
müssen genutzt werden damit die Täter
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden können
ich denke die Botschaft ist klar der
Krieg ist kein Zustand der
Gesetzlosigkeit man muss die
internationalen Abkommen einhalten
Zivilisten müssen geschützt werden es
gibt da die Genfer Konvention meine
Damen und Herren
Frau Vorsitzender ich denke bei allen
bewaffneten Konflikten geht es darum
Solidarität zu beweisen gegenüber den
Opfern und was wir jetzt Empfinden für
die Menschen in der Ukraine sollte auch
gelten für alle anderen Menschen die
sich in einer ähnlichen Situation
befinden das Schicksal vieler Afrikaner
auch für jungen Studenten
war ja häufig auch ein Weg der
erniederung Erniedrigung aufgrund ihrer
Hautfarbe haben sie gar nicht die Hilfe
und Unterstützung bekommen diese
eigentliche benötigten und auch sie
haben gelitten und hat Angst
unser Herz zerbricht natürlich
angesichts der Opfer in der Ukraine aber
wann immer
Diskriminierung praktiziert werden muss
die Menschheit
aufstehen und das anprangern damit es
nicht dazu kommt dass wir mit zweierlei
Maß messen
panzerschüssel sind nicht hinnehmbar
unabhängig davon wo sie auf der Welt
vorkommen ich denke wir müssen alles tun
um den Krieg in der Ukraine an zu dämmen
es geht darum zu verhindern dass
unschuldige Menschen
leiden getötet werden Familien zerrissen
werden und das ist Dutzende von
kriegsweisen gibt und ich denke es geht
darum die Praktiken und Grundsätze der
uno-kater hochzuhalten und wir
unterstützen jegliche Initiativen
herzlichen Dank für diese Erklärung und
jetzt hat Herr
labroffen Kollegen
ich glaube die heutige Sitzung ist dem
wunschscheinigen geschuldet und das
Thema
von schulfreiheit in der Ukraine zu
besprechen und ich glaube das ist sehr
richtig
ich glaube das was in diesem Land seit
2014 passiert mit strafflosigkeit
beschrieben werden kann
offene russofuren und Neonazis sind dann
die Macht gekommen das Ergebnis eines
und erwarteten Umsturzes mit direkt
Unterstützung der westlichen Länder und
sofort danach haben Sie sich für eine
recht freie Zone entschieden für das
Ignorieren von Redefreiheit
Recht auf Leben Meinungsfreiheit das
Recht der eigene Sprache zu nutzen bis
heute wurden Verbrechen auf dem
main-daten im Februar 2014 nicht
bestraft man hat immer noch der
Schuldigen an der schrecklichen
Tragödien und erst am 2 mai 2014 wurde
gefunden noch bestraft als im lokalen
Gewerkschaftshaus ungefähr 50 Menschen
bei lebendigem Leiber verbrannt sind
deshalb stehen die
politischen Morde von
remet und andere Journalisten und
trotzdem versucht man uns heute ein
anderes narrativ aufzuzwingen über die
russische Aggression als den Ursprung
aller Probleme dabei ignoriert man das
mehr als acht Jahre lang du keine
charmee und der
rheinischen Kämpfer straffrei Idee
Bewohner des Don Bass getötet haben und
weiter töten nur weil sie das Ergebnis
der verbrecherischen blutigen
fassungswidrigen umstoßes nicht
anerkennen wollten und ihre Rechte
schützen wollten die von der
ukrainischen Verfassung rentiert wurden
anderem auch das Recht auf den Nutzung
ihrer Muttersprache Russisch
erinnern sie sich an 2015 der
Premierminister Herr jazzynuk und gesagt
dass Unmenschen leben
und nicht weiter von ist auch der
aktuelle Präsident Herr selensky
der in einem Interview im September
letzten Jahres auf die Frage was er über
den Menschen auf dem Don Bass denkt
gesagt hat wissen sie es gibt Menschen
und es gibt Kreaturen
das heißt
einer sehr prägnante
Regimes auch unter silence alle die sich
nicht einverstanden in einverstanden
erklärt haben mit dem staatsumsturz
haben sie zu Terroristen erklärt und
seit acht Jahren hat
das
Operation gegen die friedliche
Bevölkerung durchgeführt und übrigens in
der Ukraine
also vielen Jahren eine totale
Mobilisierung der gesamten
erwachsenenbevölkerung durchgeführt
inklusiver auch der Frauen damit sie
ein die nationalistischen
Abteilung
die Regierung hat zwar gesagt sie steht
zu den minskerabkommen sie aber
sabotiert es gab eine finanzielle
verkehrsmäßiger Blockade des Don Bass
man hat keine Renten gezahlt keine
Bankdienstleistungen zur Verfügung
gestellt keine Bildung keine
Gesundheitsdienstleistungen innen wurden
elementare Bürgerrechte verwendet unter
anderem die auch von internationalen
Abkommen von 66 über kulturell und
wirtschaftliche Rechte sowie über
Bürgerrechte und politische Rechte
und dann wollte er selenskier nicht mehr
so tun und hat gesagt dass man minzknot
dafür braucht um die Sanktionen aufrecht
zu erhalten die gegen Russland
eingeführt waren noch auf war sein
Vorgänger und der Ko-Autor der Metzger
Abkommen Herr poroschenko vor ein paar
Monaten hat er öffentlich und mit Stolz
gesagt dass diese Abkommen die er
unterschrieben hat weder er noch
irgendjemand anderes in der Ukraine
hatte nicht vor sie zu erfüllen und dass
diese Abkommen nötig waren um Zeit zu
gewinnen um Waffen von dem westlichen
Ländern zu erhalten für einen Krieg mit
der russenföderation
ähnlich hat sich auch der
Sekretär des Sicherheitsrates
hat und seine Straflosigkeit verdammt
das geberische im seinen westlichen
quartoren in erster Linie Deutschland
Frankreich und natürlich den Vereinigten
Staaten
Staat vom Kiew zu verlangen dass das
minzkeabkommen ausgefüllt wird haben
Berlin Paris und Washington die
Androhungen einer gewaltlösung im Don
Bass das sogenannten B ignoriert in den
letzten Jahren hat hier war Regime einen
frontalkrieg gegen die russische Sprache
geführt und
frei durch die Bevölkerung der Ukraine
ihre Rechte verwehrt es gab skandalöser
Gesetz über die Bildung 2017 über die
ukrainische Sprache als Staatssprache in
2019 über die volle
Allgemeinbildung in 2020 über die Völker
der Ukraine in 2021 all diese zielten
darauf der russische Sprache zu
verdrängen und in faktisch völlig zu
verbieten gleichzeitig hat man Gesetze
eingeführte die die Theorie und Praxis
des Nazismus förderten
die Empfehlungen der Venedig Kommission
des Europarates des un der
menschheitskommission der
Kommissars die sprachliche Gesetzgebung
zu ändert
und diese multilateralen Strukturen
haben nicht die Kraft gefunden oder in
wurde nicht erlaub die Ukraine das ist
bringen die internationen
Verpflichtungen im Bereich der Mensch
schlechter zu erfüllen das
Bildungsministerium der Ukraine hat die
russische Sprache und russische
Literatur aus dem Schulprogramm
ausgeschlossen
werden Bücher auf Russisch verboten und
vernichtet russischer Schriftsteller
werden verboten der Staat unterstützt
die Ideologie von nationalem Hass gegen
ethnische Russen und offiziell in diesem
Land
verstecken ihre
nazi-einheit nicht mehr und rufen offen
zu Tötung von Russen auf der Wirtschaft
der Kasachstan
wieder in Kiew hat vor einem Monat in
einem Interview erklärt ich zitiere wir
versuchen Sie die Russen so viel wie
möglich zu töten je mehr Russen wir
jetzt töten desto weniger müssen unsere
Kinder töten das war's Zitat Ende hat
irgendjemand darauf hingewiesen besteht
das neue Sturm Frühling hat und der
Bürgermeister von libro filatov gesagt
zitiere es ist die Zeit für kalten Hass
wir haben das noch alle recht ganz ruhig
und klar diese Unmenschen zu töten
weltweit
unbeschränkt lange und so viel wie
möglich Zitat Ende am 13 September
diesen Jahres vor kurzem hat Herr
danielow
erklärt ich zitiere
reingehe wäre angeht werden die Bewohner
ukrainisiert egal was Sie denken nicht
nur die Russen sondern auch die
Vertreter aller
Nationalitäten wenn Sie zusätzliche auf
anderen schwachen lernen wollen noch
rumänisch polnisch Hebräisch bitte aber
nicht auf Kosten unseres Staates auf
eure Kosten können sie ihre Bildung
verbessern muss man dazu sagen dass
große Form Äußerungen völlig straflos
geblieben sind das ist ja nicht nur
russophobe
anderer Länder gesprochen andere
Nationen die in der Ukraine Leben und
der Gipfel war natürlich ein Interview
von Herrn selenskämpfern August letzten
Jahres
fühlen zum vorherigen Kinder und Enkel
nach Russland zurückkehren soll fahren
Sie nach Russland hat er gesagt und ich
glaube die
Entscheidungen die die Bewohner einer
Reihe von ukrainischen Gebieten
getroffen haben über Referenten zum
Beitritt zu Russland ist eine Antwort
auf seine Äußerung
unter dem Deckmantel des Kampfes gegen
Separatismus werden in der Ukraine
Andersdenkende verfolgt im März diesen
Jahres wurden 11 politische Parteien
verboten unter dem Vorwand ihrer
Verbindung zur Russland längst hat man
Oppositionelle Fernsehsender auf
Russisch geschlossen
Websites die der Regierung nicht gegeben
sind werden blockiert für den Ort
Versuch alternativer Sichtweisen zu
äußern werden Journalisten verfolgt die
SWU hält die ukrainische
gefangen die oftmals auch in der UN über
den Narzissmus in der Ukraine gesprochen
hat wir haben keine Zweifel dass die
Ukraine zu einem teeren Nazis statt
geworden ist wo internationale Normen
missachtet werden
es ist keine Verwunderung ist nicht
verwunderlich dass die ukrainische Armee
um die nationalistischen Abteilungen
terroristische Methoden verwendeten
Menschen als Schutzschilder verwenden
und dabei Pumpen westliche Staaten die
Ukraine mit Militärausrüstung voll sie
bilden die Armee aus und das Ziel ist
wird offen deklariert die
Kampfhandlungen so lange wie möglich
aufrecht zu erhalten trotz aller Leiden
um eurosant und möglichst so Schwächen
diese Linie bedeutet eine
direktinvolvierung der westlichen
Ukraine Konflikt und macht sie zu
Konfliktparteien eine vorsätzliche
Aufwiegelung des Konflikts durch den
kollektiven Westen bleibt auch straffrei
sie werden sich natürlich nicht selbst
bestrafen wir haben keine Illusionen
dass die russischen Armee und die
Freiwilligen von der Netze und lochansk
nicht nur gegen die Neonazi Armee Giers
entgegenstehen sondern auch die Armeen
des kollektiven Westens
in Echtzeit und den modernsten Systemen
Flugzeugen Schiffen Satelliten
strategischen
Zitronen gibt die NATO der keine Steine
datenzuführung und sagt ihnen dass
Russland im Kampf geschlagen werden muss
das sagen ganz offiziel Vertreter der
Europäischen Union und als Bestrafung
Russland jeglicher severinität verlieren
soll wissen Sie dass es nicht nur
latenterrassismus das ist offener
Rassismus von der Hintergrund von
massieren massierten Beschusses von
Orten im Don was freut sich Herr
selenski in Zitat wir spüren endlich
dass die westliche Artillerie richtig
funktioniert die Waffen die wir von
unseren Partnern erhalten haben die
Genauigkeit ist wirklich so wie wir es
brauchen sagte das war überhaupt dieses
Staatsminister und dabei gibt es
keinerlei militärische strategische
Ziele in den beschossenen horten es
wurden keine getroffen nur die
friedliche Bevölkerung des dombas leidet
seit Ende Juli haben hat die russische
Armee das Zentrum von Dennis aus der
Distanz miniert durch verbotene Anti
antisoldaten Minen das läuft der
Konvention von 1989 zu gegen und auch
das zweite Protokoll zum
genf-konvention zum Verbot von ihnen
ohne selbstliquidierung das bleibt
ebenfalls strafloss weil die Vereinigten
Staaten und ihre Alliierten Roboter
völligerische seit acht Jahren Decken
und ihre Politik gegenüber asilenz gehen
auf dem
amerikanischen Prinzip aufbauen er ist
natürlich unseren aber er ist unser
und die sogenannten Opfer der Aggression
wir hatten manchmal einfach nicht nur
vergessen sondern auch ignoriert selbst
die westliche
menschenrechtsschutzorganisationen ist
die international die man kaum der
freundlichen gegenüber Russland
Verdächtigen kann hat man in
kremlagenten das betrachtet nur weil sie
bekannte Fakten Beständigkeit das Kiew
schweres Geschütz auf zivilen Objekten
platziert straffrei bleiben auch
der Beschuss der das
Risiko keine nuklear katastrop
versteigert und das obwohl seit dem
ersten September Mitglieder der
Internationalen Energieagentur dort sind
und es überhaupt kein Problem darstellt
die Quelle des Beschusses festlegen und
der Besuch der
künstlich verzögert obwohl bereits
Anfang Julia alle Details
festgezurrt waren und die Mission
hätte aufbrechen können und danach
gab es eine sehr unschöne Situation als
die Sicherheitsabteilung des
Sekretariats die Route nicht bestätigen
wollte die ganz Russland erlaubt wurde
dann hat sie gesagt dass sie ja die
Parameter diese Mission selbst
festgelegt hat das ist wirklich nicht
schön das hat den Besuch
verzögert
um zwei Monate
aber drei Monate Entschuldigung
fast drei Monate
Soldaten die den ukrainischen
Nationalisten in die Hände gefallen sind
es gibt viele Informationen zu Folter
und außergerichtlichen
Tötungen ich bin mir sicher dass
diejenigen die sich für die Situation in
der Ukraine gesehen interessieren Video
gesehen haben wie ukrainische
Nationalisten mit russischen
[Musik]
die auf die Erde geworfen worden mit
hinter der Rücken
und mit Kopfschüssen erschossen hat
irgendjemand hier diese Verbrechen
kommentiert wir haben sehr viele Beweise
für diese und andere Verbrechen des
kiwa-regimes die seit 2014 ständig
stattfinden die russischen
Strafverfolgungsorgane arbeiten mit
denen von donesco Clans zusammen und
halten alle Verbrechen fest wir
haben mehr als 220 Personen festgelegt
und Plissee war der oberbefehlshinhabern
der Ukraine
einzelner
militären privaten die den Erschließung
von Gefangenen
befohlen haben gegen die Staatsbürger
von Kanada Großbritannien und den USA
werden
ermitteln gegen söldatum aufgenommen und
ich Versicherung dass alle Schuldigen zu
Rechenschaft gezogen werden und ich
möchte Ihre Aufmerksamkeit noch mal auf
folgendes lenken als russische Ukraine
im März sich fast gar nicht haben auf
die von Kia vorgeschlagenen Parameter
der Regulierung ist ein paar Tage später
die tragödigen Botschaft passiert
dass sie gestellt war darüber steht bei
niemand und Zweifel und ich möchte meine
liebe Herren darauf aufmerksam machen
dass die westlichen Kollegen sofort nach
dieser Inszenierung
meine Hysterie
ans Leben gerufen haben uns neue
Sanktionen und uns
ohne jegliche Beweise beschuldigt sie
will Bürger beschossen haben und als
dieser Propaganda Effekt realisiert
wurde hat sich niemand mehr als erinnert
außer uns ich finde mich noch mal in
einem Wesenheit des Generalsekretärs und
der Gärten Minister an Sie bitte
fragen Sie von der ukrainischen
Regierung dass sie einen sehr einfachen
Schritt macht dass sie die Namen der
Menschen veröffentlichen dessen Leichen
in der Stadt Butcher gezeigt worden ich
bitte seit vielen Monaten darum niemand
möchte das Hören niemand reagiert Herr
Generalsekretär sie kennen doch
wenigstens ihre Autorität dafür nutzen
ich glaube dass wir für alle nützlich
dieses Thema
zu klären und wir haben natürlich auch
gesehen dass
die internation Justiz sehr aktiv vor
dem Ukraine das werden Bemühungen um
Ermittlungen beworben die Straftaten die
russischen Soldaten zugeschrieben werden
das ist alles auch gestellt und bestellt
das sehen wir natürlich entweder der
blutige straßensturz in 2014 noch die
Tragödien und deshalb mai des gleichen
Jahres noch der Beschuss der friedlichen
Städte des Don Bass
2014 durch Flugzeuge der ukrainischen
Arme wurden nicht zum Grund für
irgendeine Reaktion seitens des
internationalen Strafgerichts und dieses
Gerichtshof hat über 3.000 Meldungen
über Verbrechen gegen die Bewohner des
dornbuz gestellt und das gab keine
Reaktion darauf jetzt ist die Leitung
dieses sogenannten Gerichts hat sie
wahrscheinlich das Befehl den Befehl von
oben erhalten
aktiv zu werden
es herrscht kein Vertrauen zu dem Organ
bei uns wir haben acht Jahre lang
vergebens gewartet bis ja die
Schlaflosigkeit in der Ukraine bekämpft
und wir hoffen nicht mehr auf
gerechtigkeitsseitens dieses und eine
Reihe anderer internationaler Institute
deshalb das Wartens ist vorbei alles was
ich gesagt habe
zeigt noch mal dass die Entscheidung
über die Durchführung der der
militärischen sonderoperation und
ausweichlich war das haben wir oft
gesagt wir haben eine riesige Anzahl an
Tatsachen vorgelegt die zeigen
von Anti Russland spielen wollte bei
einer Plattform für Bedrohungen gegen
russische Sicherheit und ich versichere
Ihnen das werden wir nicht zulassen
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
schon
danke
Darlegungen nun bitte der
Außenminister des Vereinigten
Königreichs von Großbritannien und
Nordirland
frau Präsidentin Herr general
vielen Dank
77 Jahren
vereinbarten die Mitglieder die
Grundsätze der uno-kater die
entscheidend sind für internationalen
Frieden und Sicherheit
unter anderem geht es um Gewaltverzicht
theodoriale
Integrität und Unabhängigkeit aller
Staaten dennoch hat vor sieben Monaten
präsent Putin den Befehl gegeben die
Ukraine
rechtswidrig und ohne
Rechtfertigung zu attackieren einen
Überfall durchzuführen
am 17 Februar hatte er sich vorher schon
geäußert
die Verteidigungsbereitschaft und
der stolze Widerstand der Ukraine ist
eine Inspiration für die freien Völker
und Nationen überall auf der Welt jeden
Tag werden die verheerenden Folgen der
russischen Invasion deutlicher die
Einrichtung der Vereinten Nationen haben
mehr als 14.000 zivile
Opfer bisher gezählt
und wahrscheinlich dürfte die Gesamtzahl
deutlich höher liegen mehr als 17
Millionen
Ukrainer sind in humanitären Notlagen
Millionen sind in der Ukraine als
Binnenvertriebene woanders hingeflogen
und
Millionen ins Ausland wir sehen die
verhängnisvollen Folgen der russischen
Gräueltaten gegen Zivilisten
beschließungen von Wohngebieten Angriffe
auf über 200 medizinische Einrichtungen
und
400 Schulen und derartige Einrichtungen
außerdem schreckliche Vorfälle in Form
sexueller Gewalt wir entnehmen dem
Bericht des
hochkommissars für Menschenrechte dass
in den russisch kontrollierten Gebieten
Zivilisten gefoltert werden
willkürlich festgehalten werden und
zwangsweise nach Russland deportiert
werden
und wir haben in istium noch weitere
schreckliche Entdeckungen machen müssen
nicht Ukraine sind die Opfer nicht nur
die Ukraine
Nöte Hunger sind von Präsident Putin
weltweit verbreitet worden Millionen von
Menschen sind in Hunger und Not gestürzt
worden durch diesen Überfall und
Russland und das haben wir heute wieder
gehört russland versucht immer noch jede
Verantwortung zurückzuweisen die Schuld
wird den zugewiesen die mit Recht
Sanktionen gegen Brite die Putins Regime
beschlossen haben als Reaktion auf seine
rechtswidrige Handlungsweise
folgendes muss klar sein wir
sanktionieren keine
Lebensmittellieferungen die Handlungen
Russlands verhindern dass Lebensmittel
das Düngemittel in Entwicklungsländer
gelangen es ist die russische Taktik es
sind die russischen Bomben die Schuld
sind an der Zerstörung der
Bauernhöfe und der Infrastruktur in der
Ukraine und das ist der Grund für die
Behinderung der ausführen ich habe im
Februar die russischen Vertreter
zugehört der dem Rat versichert hatte
Russland habe keineswegs die Absicht das
Nachbarland mit einer Invasion zu
überziehen wir wissen nun dass das
damals eine Lüge war und heute habe ich
weiteren Lieferungen dieses russischen
lügenkatalogs voller Verzerrungen und
Ehrlichkeit und Fehlinformationen
zuhören müssen er ist jetzt aus dem Saal
herausgegangen das überrascht mich nicht
ich glaube herlabroff möchte die
kollektive Verurteilung durch diesen
Draht nicht mithören
aber wir haben ihn damals durchschaut
und durchschauen ihn heute ein weiteres
Mal
uns liegen Informationen vor wir wissen
dass Russland dabei ist
Schein Referenten abzuhalten auf
souveränen Staatsgebiet der Ukraine oder
jede Rechtsgrundlage unter
Gewaltandrohung
massenvertreibungen von Menschen sind
vorgenommen worden in Gebieten die
überwältigend für die Unabhängigkeit der
Ukraine gestimmt haben
wir wissen was Vladimir Putin tut
er hat vor
das Ergebnis dieser Referenten
vorwegzunehmen und zu beeinflussen er
will das als Vorwand nehmen um
souveränes ukrainisches Staatsgebiet für
annektieren und will das als weiteren
Vorwand dafür nutzen eine Eskalation
seiner Aggression zu betreiben das sind
seine Pläne das hat er vor und wir
möchten alle Staaten aufrufen dies
zurückzuweisen und es abzulehnen die
artige Ergebnisse wie sie vorgelegt
werden
anzuerkennen wir haben die russischen
Lügen und Verzerrungen erleben müssen
wissen wir müssen jetzt den Aussagen der
Ukrainer zuhören die uns die Wahrheit
sagen die uns die Wirklichkeit
beschreiben
die Präsident Putins Krieg verursacht
hat
Dr Olena josevak
ihr Mann Wolle und der 22-Jährige
gesunde Mitri wurden von russischen
Streitkräften aus ihrer Wohnung in Costa
mal bei Bucher im März entführt
verschleppt
russische
Soldaten schossen Ole zweimal in die
Beine bevor alle
allen die Augen verbunden wurden sie in
Truppentransporter gebracht werden und
ich möchte sie einmal zitieren ihre
eigene Geschichte zitieren zuerst einmal
brachten wir uns in ein zerbombtes Haus
die russischen Soldaten sagten sie
würden uns umbringen mein Mann musste
stundenlang auf dem Boden liegen in
seinem eigenen Blut
ich weiß nicht warum wir haben nichts
Böses getan dann führten sie mein Sohn
weg ich weiß nicht wohin ich weiß nicht
ob sie ihn jemals wiedersehen können ich
will ganz einfach meinen Jungen zurück
haben indesitats
wohleders Geschichte und die viele viele
andere beschreiben uns die Wahrheit die
Wirklichkeit das ist ein annexionskrieg
ein Eroberungskrieg
Präsident Putin will jetzt noch mehr
russische junge Männer und Frauen
dorthin entsenden und den Frieden noch
weil noch weniger wahrscheinlich werden
lassen
Putin muss verstehen dass die Welt
zuschaut und dass wir nicht gleichgültig
bleiben werden wir als Mitglieder des
Sicherheitsrats müssen eindeutig die
russischen Bemühungen zurückweisen
ukrainisches Gebiet für annektieren wir
müssen Putin erklären dass sein Angriff
auf ukrainische Menschen aufhören muss
das ist keine straftfreiheit für
diejenigen geben kann die Gräueltaten
begehen und dass er sich aus der Ukraine
zurückziehen muss und
die regionale und globale Stabilität
wiederherstellen muss wenn er wollte
könnte er diesen Krieg beenden ein Krieg
der die Ukraine und das russische Volk
unendlich
geschädigt hat verletzt hat verwundet
hat ein Angriff auf die Karte der
Vereinten Nationen Angriff auf die
internationalen Normen die uns alle
schützen sollen wir stehen an der Seite
unserer ukrainischen Freunde solange wir
es nötig ist
die Ukrainer kämpfen für ihre Freiheit
und das ist der Kampf der Welt für die
Freiheit unser Freiheitskampf und wenn
die Souveränität der Ukraine und der
Staatsgebiet der Ukraine nicht geachtet
werden dann ist kein einziges Land
wirklich sicher das ist der Grund dafür
dass die Ukraine gewinnen kann und
gewinnen muss
für seine Stellungnahme
danken und ich darf jetzt Frau
Butch
die Botschafterin die ausmesserung von
Ghana bitten das Wort zu ergreifen
herzlichen Dank liebe sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin für die Organisation dieses
Treffens und ich darf auch dem
Generalsekretär Antonius gut theres
stanken
dass hier mit seinem ganz mit seiner
ganz klaren Ansprache ein Zeichen
gesetzt hat und wir danken auch Herrn
Karin Kahn dem chefan Kläger des
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof die
Welt steht
in Einigkeit seit davor und in der
Resolution 1593 von 2005 also von 20
Jahren wird ja festgestellt dass die
Straflosigkeit zu irgendwo auf der Welt
eine großartige heraus große
Entschuldigung eine große
Herausforderung für die weltweite
Sicherheit ist wir haben systematisch
unsere Institutionen gestärkt und auch
ganz klare
Regierungsführung festgeschrieben und
auch Sanktionen für all gegen all
diejenigen die tatsächlich unsere Normen
und unsere Standards verletzen kein
Staat
unabhängig davon wie mächtig er ist darf
sich dem entziehen und
[Musik]
die den Rahmen der weltweiten
Zivilisation verlassen das Leben und
Eigentum der Menschen die schwächer sind
gefährden und deshalb müssen ja auch die
Mitglieder dieses Rats hier dringlich
und einig reagieren um die
Lähmung des Sicherheitsrats der
Vereinten Nationen auch zu verhindern
die Folgen des Krieges in der Ukraine
sind ganz einfach
inakzeptabel und wir
dürfen auch nicht zulassen dass es zur
Straflosigkeit für der Russen in der
Ukraine kommt denn die Folgen dafür
messen davon wären tatsächlich nicht
vorauszusehen
Ghana ist tatsächlich sehr beunruhigt
über die Entwicklung des Krieges in der
Ukraine
aufgrund der Angriffe auf zivile
Städte und Gemeinden und
Infrastruktureinrichtungen wir bedauern
sehr dass die
Grundrechte die tatsächlich die das
Kriegsrecht und so weiter die
Zivilbevölkerung schützen sollen hier
von den Aggressionen nicht respektiert
wurden wir sind
hört über die
humanitären Bedrohungen die Wert dieses
Krieges aufgetaucht sind 14 Millionen
Menschen vor allen Dingen Frauen und
Kinder
mussten aus ihren Häusern fliehen und
sind tatsächlich auch der
sexuellen Belästigungen durch Soldaten
ausgesetzte die Menschen werden dort
gefoltert die Freiheitsrechte und
Menschenrechte der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung werden verletzt und wir sind
tatsächlich auch sehr besorgt über die
offensichtlichen
Bedrohungen mit Atomwaffen
denn aufgrund des der
ständigen Militär schon Angriffe auf das
Atomkraftwerk von saporiscia da haben
wir ganz besondere Sorgen um die
nukleare Sicherheit und wir sagen wir
brauchen hier eine sichere
Sicherheitszone wir unterstützen die
Anstrengungen der Italia internationalen
Atome Energiebehörde im Hinblick auf die
Verhinderung einer nuklearen Katastrophe
mit den Folgen für die Zivilbevölkerung
und wir sagen angesichts weiterer
Menschenrechtsverletzungen müssen wir
als Rat ein ganz klares Beispiel
aussenden das die Aggressoren die für
solche Gold hatten verantwortlich sind
auch zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden wir
dürfen dies nicht als einfacher
kriegsfolge hinnehmen wir sagen auch
dass die hier insbesondere es nicht zur
Straflosigkeit des Aggressors kommen
kann und wir stimmen freuen uns für
Sanktionen aus und wir sagen
sämtliche
Täter von Kriegsverbrechen müssen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden
Straflosigkeit ist keine Option wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die Reihe
dieser Gräueltaten tatsächlich auch
transparent und sorgfältig und
unabhängig untersucht und ermittelt
werden damit wir die Fakten überhaupt
einmal feststellen können und dann die
Möglichkeit haben über den
internationalen
scharfgerichtsgerichtshof hier für
rechts zu sorgen keiner unterstützt
diese juristischen Maßnahmen
insbesondere auch die
ermittlungsvorgänge die der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof und der
Menschenrechtsrat der Vereinten Nationen
gerade unternimmt wir besorgen uns um
die
Opfer für des Krieges in der Ukraine und
wir fordern dann natürlich auch
Unterstützung und Hilfe für die
Opfer insbesondere für
und die Opfer die Frauen die Opfer
geworden sind von sozialen von sexualen
sexuellen Belästigungen
frau Präsidentin
wir haben schon mehrfach eine ganz klare
Stellung bezogen gegen den Aggressor in
der Ukraine und wir sagen er muss nach
dem internationalen Recht und den
Grundsätzen der Kater der Vereinten
Nationen zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden
die Ukraine ist ein souveränes Mitglied
der Vereinten Nationen und sie haben
tatsächlich alles recht und sogar die
Verantwortung ihre territoriale
Integrität und politische Unabhängigkeit
zu verteidigen und wir
ziehen den Hut vor der
Widerstandsfähigkeit und dem Mut der
ukrainischen Truppen wir werden auf
keinen Fall irgendwelche
Gebietsansprüche akzeptieren die Uni die
einseitig von
Russland jetzt erhoben werden gegen die
Ukraine und wir fordern die russischen
Aggressoren auf jetzt sofort ihre
militärischen Operationen einzustellen
sich zurückzuziehen hinter die
anerkannte Grenze der Ukraine und die
politische Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine zu
respektieren wir brauchen dann einen
diplomatischen Prozess
der Krieg selbst führte nicht dazu
sondern er führt allen nur dazu das
weiterhin Menschenleben auf beiden
Seiten geopfert werden die Kosten dieses
Krieges sind jetzt schon sehr hoch nicht
nur für die beiden Kriegsparteien
sondern auch für den Rest der Welt
wie der Präsident von Ghana gestern in
seiner in seiner Rede gesagt hat vor der
Vollversammlung ich glaube das Zitieren
jede Kugel jede Bombe jede Rakete die
ein Ziel in der Ukraine trifft trifft
unser Portemonnaie und unsere
Volkswirtschaften in Afrika Zitat Ende
lassen Sie mich dann noch einmal für das
Protokoll sagen wir danken dem
Generalsekretär für seine großartigen
Bemühungen das
der Menschen weltweit zu mindern damit
sie nicht zu sehr unter der Konsequenzen
dieses Krieges und diesen Blutvergießen
zu leiden haben und
oder er hat ja dafür gesorgt dass
weiterhin Getreide geliefert wird aus
der Ukraine damit die
Nahrungsmittelsicherheit die
Ernährungssicherheit gewährleistet ist
es geht ja hier auch um den Ersatz von
russischen und ukrainischen Getreide und
entsprechenden Düngemitteln frau
Präsidentin das ist nämlich mit einem
appellenden in der Woche in der die
Augen der Welt auf uns schauen und
Millionen Menschen von den Vereinten
Nationen hier auch eine Führungsrolle
erwarten müssen wir eine starke
Botschaft aussenden das Straflosigkeit
nicht toleriert wird keine Option ist
dass wir durch konzertierte
diplomatische Bemühungen handeln müssen
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
der Konflikte no crane effects also ich
bin in regence far from wear
betrifft uns alle auch in ganz
entgegenden Gebiete der Sicherheit
zu finden die einen dauerhaften deswegen
muss sicherstellen in dieser Woche
begehen wir den
innocenters
der schon sechs Monate zurückliegt es
gibt Millionen von Flüchtlingen und
binnenverschriebene deren Rückkehr in
ihrer Heimat unsicher ist
und es ist so viele stehen vor der
Perspektive einer sich verschlimmernden
humanitären Krise in diesen sieben
Monaten hat dieser
Rat verschiedene Berichte
entgegengenommen über
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in der
konfliktion vor allen Dingen auch gegen
schutzbedürftige alten Frauen und Kinder
Brasilien
verurteilt
diesen Übergriffe und spricht sich aus
für eine unparteiische Untersuchung
damit die Verantwortlichen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden das
humanitäre Völkerrecht muss von allen
Parteien eingehalten werden das fordern
wir Frau Vorsitzende wir haben einen
dringliche Aufgabe vor uns die Parteien
müssen zum Dialog kommen um eine
sofortige Waffenruhe herbeizuführen und
die Aufnahme von Verhandlungen für einen
Friedensvertrag die Fortsetzung der
Feindseligkeit
gefährdet das Leben
unschuldiger Zivilisten und gefährdet
das Überleben von Millionen von Familien
in anderen Regionen insbesondere in den
Entwicklungsländern das Risiko einer
Eskalation des Konfliktes ist einfach zu
groß
und die Konsequenzen für die Weltordnung
sind unvorhersehbar nur
Diplomatie bietet eine mögliche Lösung
für Konflikte zwischen Staaten es ist
nicht der Zeitpunkt bekommen
die Vision einzelner Parteien
hochzuhalten diese Rat muss dafür sorgen
dass die Parteien auf dem
Verhandlungswege eine friedliche Lösung
des Konfliktes suchen vielen dank vielen
Dank
und als nächstes hat die Außenministerin
von Kenia Frau reschel um Marmor das
Wort
bedeutet
auch das Starten unterschiedlich
reagiert haben auf den Krieg und
berührenzen
Weltordnung von seinem Gegenteil zu
trennen in der man Kater sind
Verhaltensregel für Staaten festgelegt
laut im Prinzipien das Hybridität
nachbarschaftlichkeit von territuellen
Integrität was sie Sicherheit und
Wohlstand der Staaten erhört unabhängig
von Größe oder stärker Frau Vorsitzender
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
werden bei ihrem eindeutigen Aufruf
bleiben an alle
recht zu achten unter anderem auch
Interessantes Recht in der Messer
Kanon Kontext
ständige Verletzungen des Rechts rufen
unsere große Sorgen hervor insbesondere
für die Zivilbevölkerung
der möchten auch unterstreichen dass die
Lage von Frauen und Kindern gerade
derjenigen die ihrer Häuser verlassen
mussten
und wir werden
sexueller Gewalt und Misshandlung
ausgesetzt sind unter anderem auch durch
Menschenhändler wir alle wissen
Leiden dieser Krieg und dieser Konflikt
für Frauen und Mädchen bringt deswegen
begrüßen wir die Arbeit unter anderem
von un-organen
wenn man bedenkt welche Auswirkungen
dieser Krieg und gerade für Frauen und
Mädchen hat
die Kampfhandlungen müssen so schnell
wie möglich aufhören
das endgültige Ziel ist der Frieden
und nicht die Nachhaltigkeit dieses
Friedens
heißt das alle die
ankriegsverbrechen beteiligt sind zur
Rechenschaft bezogen werden müssen und
es ist auch sehr wichtig dass Frauen
vollumfänglich an der Beilegung des
Konflikts beteiligt sind
das kommt nicht nur daher wir Sie diesen
Krieg erleben dass es auch sehr
bedeutend für den nachfolgenden fliegen
Frau Vorsitzender die war eher sind
immer für Dialog und deeskalationen
angetreten
hier obwohl in einem Konsens erreichen
damit es eine internationale Stabilität
gibt
erinnern auch
die keine
Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen zu einer
nach unten führenden Spirale führen und
da ist internationales Recht genauso wie
nationales Recht
es ist sehr wichtig ein konstruktiven
inklusiven Dialog aufrecht zu erhalten
Kommunikationskanäle offen zu erhalten
sowie
Perspektiven für eine diplomatische
Regulierung
die ganze vielfältige Welt ist besorgt
darum was die Konsequenz ist Krieges für
die Nahrungsmittel und Energiesicherheit
also die für das diskussionsrisiko
bedeutet deswegen müssen wir
zusammenarbeiten unsere Pflicht erfüllen
innerhalb und die wichtigsten Probleme
weltweit überwinden
und zurückzuwerfen
dieser Ansatz
folgt auch aus unserem Erfahrungen im
neuen Osten
den wir auf Hegemonie bestehen mitten
auf einem Null zum Spiel dann werden
alle Menschen leiden vielen Dank
möchte sie loben für ihre
Führungsaufgabe und auch für die
Tätigkeit Frankreichs und auch die
Arbeiten von Herrn Karim Krahn
die sich alle dafür eingesetzt haben die
Gründe Frage weiterzubringen das ist ein
eine schwere Verletzung der Karte der
Vereinten Nationen die Verpflichtung die
sehr durch alle in Kredit alle
Mitgliedsstaaten einzuhalten die weiter
untergraben sollte etwas unterrum werden
um den Rechtscharakter der Gebiete in
der osttürkeiine zu ändern
wir leben im Augenblick in großer Gefahr
für den Weltfrieden für die
internationale Sicherheit
ist im Gange
wir befürchtet von der
Völkergemeinschaft die potenzielle
Stationierung von
Massenvernichtungswaffen im Rahmen
dieses Konfliktes ist ein Thema auf dem
Schlachtfeld werden Zivilisten schwer
geschädigt unter Verstoß gegen die
grundlegenden Bestimmungen
das ist darüber aus bedrohliche
Situation
also wo Nationen Disziplinarmaßnahmen
gegen Soldaten ergreifen wollen die sich
in weigern bestimmte Taten durchzuführen
müssen bestraft werden wenn sie
derartige Taten befürworten alle
Parteien auch
diejenigen die sich für
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
beschäftigen sind aufgerufen
die in die Behauptungen und
Beschuldigungen aufzugreifen und
unparteiliche Ermittlungen durchzuführen
wir verlangen die Rechenschaftspflicht
für
kriegsbezogene Rechtsverletzungen
Gewissen dass der Schutz der Zivilisten
nötig ist und den Krieg zu beenden gehen
jeden Ruf dementsprechend auf zur
sofortigen Einstellungen der
Feindseligkeiten
sollte eine vermittelte Einigung
herbeigeführt werden und der Wahrung der
tätigen Integrität der Ukraine und der
Souveränität des Landes unter
Berücksichtigung der Interessen aller
Beteiligten
frau Präsidentin die Lage in der Ukraine
unterstreicht die Notwendigkeit
tiefgreifender Reformen des
Sicherheitsrats der Vereinten Nationen
hat in einer für unseren Parlament
aufgerufen zur Demokratisierung des
Sicherheitsrats
wenn nur die gefährdete Legitimität des
Rates nicht ganz zerstört werden soll
unter Präsident hat ein Weckruf ergehen
lassen es ist an der Zeit meint er dass
der Rat entschieden seine Stimme hören
lässt auch die Stimme Afrikas und zwar
durch eine Reform der
mitgliedschaftsregelung wir begrüßen die
Ankündigung von Präsident Biden die eine
Ausweitung der betrieblichen
Sicherheitsrat verlangt
in der Ukraine kommt es darauf an dass
eine solche Aufforderung ein wirklichen
Wandel durchzuführen die gehört werden
muss
alle beteiligten Händler Beschäftigte
Arbeiter in Afrika müssen dass ihr Leben
und ihre Sicherheit geschützt werden vor
der Klimakrise die
die auf der Tagesordnung des
Sicherheitsrats stehen müssen gelöst
werden dürfen nicht an den Rand gedrängt
werden wegen des Ukraine Kriegs der
schützt die Interessen im Sicherheitsrat
wenn nicht die ohne Kater verändert wird
nur eine ständige Mitgliedschaft
afrikanischer Staaten kann uns hier
weiterhelfen die fordert also die
gesamten ständige Mitglieder auf sich
uneingeschränkt hinter dieses Ziel zu
stellen das ist die einzige Möglichkeit
dieser Einrichtung weltweit die
Legitimität zu verleihen die zu einer
guten Zusammenarbeit führen kann frau
Präsidentin ich
begrüße es wenn die Einrichtungen
Vereinten Nationen sich weiterhin darum
bemühen das Leiden der Betroffenen zu
lindern die unter dem Krieg in der
Ukraine zu leiten haben wir
unintelligible
Souveränität und die gerade Integrität
der Ukraine in den Interessen Grenzen
gewahrt bleibt ich danke für das
freundliche zuhören
sehen
Metro Düsseldorf
erraten und sehr geehrter Herr
Generalsekretär ich glaube dass wir sie
die wohl dringlichsten Bedrohungen hier
ganz klar
genannt haben nämlich die russische
Bedrohung der ukrainen wir haben wir
finden immer noch weiter wir exklumieren
immer noch weiter
die Leichname von
Opfern der russischen Aggressoren in
Issum haben wir über 440 Leichname
gefunden zum Teil auch nur Leichenteile
in einem die Trauer
die
Leben ist nur ein weiterer Tropfen von
dem Ozean des Leids den dass die Russen
den
Ukrainern seit acht Jahren auferlegt
haben viele von ihnen haben sicherlich
das Bild der Hand an der Tod eines toten
ukrainischen Soldaten gesehen mit einem
gelben und mit einem gelbblauen Armband
dass er immer noch trug ich trage ja
auch solch einen Armband sehen so viele
von uns tun das
und
Russland sollte eins wissen
es wird überhaupt nie in der Lage sein
uns alle umzubringen und hier ist der
Grund dafür denn im 24 februar ist
Russland die Ukraine von aus allen
Richtungen angegriffen hat sind 10.000
von Ukrainern aus dem Ausland
zurückgekommen innerhalb von 24 Stunden
um hier Heimatland zu verteidigen und
was in den ersten 24 Stunden nach der
Mobilisierung dass der von Präsident
Putin angekündigten Mobilisierung
passierte jetzt nach der
teilmobilisierung das Gegenteil in Kraft
nämlich tausende verließen Buchten Flüge
ins Ausland gestern hat so Putin die
teilmobilisierung angekündigt aber er
hat da tatsächlich nur seine Niederlage
angekündigt der kann 300.000 500.000
Menschen in den Krieg werfen aber sie
werden Herr Putin werden diesen Krieg
nie gewinnen heute ist jeder Ukraine
eine Waffe ey bereit sein Land der
Ukraine zu verteidigen und die
Grundsätze die in der Karte der
Vereinten Nationen stehen Russland wird
vollends zur Verantwortung und zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden für diese
Kriegsverbrecher und die Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit gestern hat
Präsident selensky ja in seiner
Ansprache ganz klar gesagt dass die
Verantwortung der Russen ein
unerlässliches Thema für die
internationale Sicherheit und den
Frieden sind die Ukraine wird sich
weiterhin mit dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof bemühen und auch mit
allen anderen Ländern die die Arbeit
dieses Gerichtshofs unterstützen und die
Ukraine unterstützen die Beweise zu
ermitteln für russische Kriegsverbrechen
wird vertrauen dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof und es wird
Gerechtigkeit Geschehen nicht nur wir
sprechen ja nicht nur wir tun das nicht
nur für die Opfer sondern auch für die
Menschen in der Ukraine in Zukunft den
Zukunft leben werden und auch für die
Menschen weltweit keinen Frieden ohne
Gerechtigkeit ich unterstreiche noch
einmal dass keines dieser keines dieser
Verbrechen in der Ukraine möglich
gewesen wäre wenn nicht die russische
Führung so verbrecherisch gehandelt
hätte und deshalb muss Präsident Putin
und seine Umgebung zu Verantwortung
gezogen werden vor einem speziellen vor
einem Sondergerichtshof und ich
appelliere an alle Staaten genau dies
auch zu unterstützen damit die
Grundsätze der Menschlichkeit und der
Kater der Vereinten Nationen auch zur
Geltung kommen meine Damen und Herren
viele hören heute mir zu mit einer Frage
im Hinterkopf gibt es eine Chance für
den Frieden wird die Ukraine mit
Russland verhandelt um diesen Krieg zu
gewinnen wenn ich möchte Kristall also
glasklar sagen keine anderen Nationen
weltweit
sehnt sich mehr nach Frieden als die
Ukraine
hat das ganz klar gestern auch noch mal
zum Ausdruck gebracht wir wollten
anderes als Frieden und stabile
Entwicklung wir wollten diesen Krieg
nicht und wir haben ihn uns auch nicht
ausgesucht
wir wollen nur ganz ein ganz normales
Leben führen weil es nur den nachfolio
aber das reicht natürlich nicht für die
eu-reine dass wenn wir uns Frieden
wünschen die Russen müssen auch über die
diplomatischen Kanäle dem Frieden eine
Chance geben aber die suchen ja bisher
nur eine militärische Lösung sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier
haben wir seit
1954 schon viele Krisen erlebt in diesen
Hallen hier aber das ist etwa eine ganze
außergewöhnliche Situation wir
konzentrieren uns heute auf die
Verbrechen die von russischen Soldaten
begangen wurden aber
sie glauben bestimmt nicht dass das die
einzigen sind die
Leute umbringen Leute kastrieren das
glaubt der irrt sich russische
Diplomaten sind kompl ein unmittelbarer
Komplizen denn ihre Lügen erbringen
diese Verbrechen nur hervor und decken
sie noch ganz offensichtlich ist ja der
einzige Punkt in der Rede Russlands hier
ist der die
unangemessene Rede
wenn er über den Präsident der Ukraine
sprach ich habe heute auch festgestellt
dass die russischen Diplomaten genauso
schnell fliehen wie die russischen
Soldaten
vor dem 24 Februar hatten die russischen
Diplomaten hier bei der UNO die Absicht
der Aggression des Angriffs der Ukraine
geleugnet der russische Präsident hat
das selbst getan er hat damals gesagt er
habe keine Pläne für einen Angriff auf
die Ukraine und das war nur wenige Tage
vor der vor dem Angriff am 24 Februar
Russland
sitzt hier seit
begleiten im Sicherheitsrat und man
spricht sich davon völlige
Straflosigkeit die Russen sind sich die
glauben dass sie mit allem davonkommen
und deshalb auch alles tun und lassen
können was sie wollen
sie können Grenzen verletzen in einem
Stil wie das in einem imperialistischen
Stil der im 19 Jahrhundert noch
gewöhnlich war und sie glauben sie
können ein Land bombardieren
sie glauben sie können Sie die
Zivilbevölkerung eines anderen Landes
und die Infrastruktur dort bombardieren
sie glauben sie können können mit
Atomwaffen drohen und dafür müssen sie
zur Verantwortung gezogen werden diese
Verantwortung diese Rechenschaft ist ein
ganz zentraler Punkt wir müssen eine
ganz klar machen dass diese Verbrechen
bestraft werden müssen denn sonst fühlen
sich andere Mächte in dieser Welt noch
versucht den in die russischen
Fußstapfen zu treten
und
jetzt kann einfach nicht akzeptiert
werden dass ein Land die Grenzen zu
einem anderen Land in Frage stellen wenn
russisch wenn wir das bei Russland
akzeptieren warum sollten wir das bei
anderen nicht akzeptieren wir sprechen
nicht nur über Russland die weltweite
sicherheitskrise greift viel weiter wir
müssen uns klar machen dass am 24
Februar 2022 Russland nicht nur die
Ukraine angegriffen hat sondern dass sie
tatsächlich den Grundfesten der Kater
der Vereinten Nationen einen schlimmen
einen schweren Schlag versetzt haben und
die Russen haben die gemeinsamen
Grundsätze auf die wir uns alle nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg verständigt haben
skrupellos verletzt Russland ist das
egal es gibt aber 192 andere UNO
Mitgliedsstaaten in Afrika in Asien in
dem im Pazifik im Nahen Osten in
Lateinamerika und in Europa all die
natürlich die Karte der Vereinten
Nationen weiterhin respektiert sehen und
die Ukraine kämpft für die Grundsätze
dieser Kater insbesondere für den
Grundsatz der territorialen Integrität
Frau Präsidenten der russische
Aggressionskrieg hat die Welt in eine
große Krise gestürzt die viele Facetten
hat und das geht viel weit über die
Ukraine hinaus
die russischen Kriegsschiffe haben die
ukrainischen Häfen blockiert und da
wurde ganz klar dass die ukrainischen
Getreidelieferungen wichtig sind für die
Ernährungssicherheit weltweit russland
hat dadurch Millionen von Menschen in
Asien in Afrika und anderen und
Bereichen in anderen Regionen der Welt
dem Risiko des Hungers ausgesetzt und
deshalb darf ich aber ganz besonders
heute dem Herrn Generalsekretär Antonio
guteres und der Türkei danken dass sie
die Initiative ergriffen haben und
Lieferungen aus der Ukraine ermöglicht
haben Putin hat gesagt das meiste
Getreide während wäre in die Europäische
Union geschickt worden das stimmt aber
gar nicht zwei Drittel des der Getreide
Lieferungen gingen nach Asien nach
Afrika und wir haben in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten
also ganz erhebliche Preiserhöhungen bei
Lebensmitteln gesehen und das ist für
die ganze Welt ein Problem die
getreideliefer Initiative durch die
durch das Schwarze Meer ist heute
bedroht denn wir hatten ja
wir haben gesagt dass wir jetzt
weiter liefern müssen und wir dürfen
einfach nicht zulassen dass Russland
dieses Spiel mit dem Hunger der Welt
weiterführt sondern wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir in vollem Umfang
weiterhin Getreide ausführen können wir
müssen den diplomatischen Druck auf
Moskau nicht erhalten damit wir bis
November und über den November hinaus
weiterhin Getreide liefern können die
Ukraine bleibt ein Garant für die
internationale Ernährungssicherheit und
wir haben deshalb beschlossen dass wir
auch humanitäre Hilfe nach
Äthiopien und Somalia leisten werden und
dorthin spezielle Getreidelieferungen
tätigen werden wir wollen unsere
exportvolumina im Rahmen des
unernährungsprogramms auch noch erhöhen
Russland
genutzte Nahrung und die Energie als
Waffen in diesem Krieg er schickte
Panzer in die Ukraine um Ukraine und
Ukrainerinnen umzubringen und er setzte
tatsächlich das den Wohlstand aller
europäischen Haushalte aufs Spiel er
spielt mit dem Hunger in Afrika in Asien
und anderen Regionen wir sitzen alle im
selben Boot wir alle Europäer die
Asiaten die Afrikaner die arabischen
Nationen Lateinamerika wir sitzen alle
in einem Boot und wir müssen die diese
Bedrohung gemeinsam bewältigen es gibt
hier keinen Raum für Neutralität ich
sagte im Februar schon hier vor den
Vereinten Nationen dass keine Nationen
in der Lage sein wird diese Krise die
durch Russland verursacht wurde
auszusetzen die beste Reaktion auf diese
Krise ist unterstützen sie die Ukraine
unterstützen Sie die Karte der Vereinten
Nationen
Russland spricht sehr gerne über die
entwickelte Welt und die
Entwicklungsländer und der Russland
unterscheidet sehr gerne dazwischen wir
machen das nicht wir unterscheiden das
nicht alle Menschen haben ein normales
Lied ein normales Leben Sicherheit
Wohlstand und Ernährung verdient wir
müssen also jetzt auch dafür sorgen dass
diese Erpressung durch die Russen ein
Ende kommt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der wichtigste Pfeil
Kinder die Sicherheit die
Sicherheitsarchitektur stärkt die
Ukraine arbeitet weiter mit Partnern
zusammen um diese
Sicherheitsaspekte zu befördern und ich
glaube das ist unser Beitrag für den
internationalen Frieden und die
internationale Sicherheit herzlichen
Dank
für ihre Ausführung und jetzt hat man
die papsi der Außenminister Tschechiens
das Wort Präsident vielen Dank
Herr Generalsekretär Exzellenzen
Präsidenten
bei dem französischen Vorsitz dafür dass
ich Gelegenheit habe an dieser wichtigen
Teil Sitzung teilzunehmen die technische
Republik ist im Augenblick
Ratspräsidentschaft innerhalb der EU der
unterstützen die Kater der Vereinten
Nationen und Tschechien hat pro Kopf die
größte Anzahl von ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen aufgenommen mehr als
400.000
Russlands anlassloser
illegaler Krieg gegen die Ukraine
bedeutet dass die schutzbedürftigsten
Mitglieder der Gesellschaft betroffen
sind und gezwungen sind zu fliehen die
russische Aggression ist wahrscheinlich
die größte Herausforderung für den
Weltfrieden in Jahrzehnten heute ist es
die Ukraine morgen kann es ein anderes
Land sein im August
1968 war es die Tschechoslowakei
in die Truppen unter
moskausführung einmarschierten der
sogenannte Prager Frühling sollte damit
unterdrückt werden und mein Land wurde
dadurch eine besetzte Kolonie wir hören
jetzt davon dass Schein Referenden in
Teilen der Ukraine anberaumt werden so
eine Russland kann hier nicht das Gebiet
eines anderen Staates einfach rauben die
imperialistischen Bestrebungen Russlands
müssen abgeschmettert werden und es geht
darum dass wir uns einsetzen für eine
multilaterale Welt wo die Regeln den
Frieden schützen wir sind empört
angesichts der Gräueltaten die Russland
in mariopol irpin Butcher illion und
anderen Orts angerichtet hat
und
Berichte über die sogenannten
filtrationslager beunruhigen und diese
Lager werden von Russland in der Ukraine
unterhalten Hunderttausende von Bürgern
der Ukraine wurden deportiert nach
Russland darunter auch Kindern es gibt
Beweise für sexuelle Verbrechen die als
Mittel der Kriegsführung eingesetzt
werden die Täter müssen zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden wir begrüßen die
Bemühungen des Generalsekretärs eine
sondierungsmission in die UK eine
zuzusetzen mehr als 40 Länder darunter
auch Tschechien
haben den ICC angerufen angesichts der
Lage in der Ukraine und der ICC
untersucht ja schon die Lage in den
ukrainen wir haben ein Staats geschafft
in Sand um den ICC zu unterstützen und
wir fordern ein internationales
Sondergericht um das Verbrechen der
Aggression durch Russland zu ahnenden
tschechische
Strafverfolgungsbehörden haben auch
Ermittlungen angestellt
aber der Grundlage des Grundsatzes der
universellen Rechtsprechung der
Sicherheitsrat und seine Mitglieder
haben die globale Verantwortung für
Frieden und völkerrechten bitte handeln
sie wir brauchen Frieden in der Ukraine
wir müssen den Respekt für die unocata
und das Völkerrecht wiederherstellen wir
brauchen Gerechtigkeit für die
Opfer und die Täter dürfen nicht
ungestraft davon kommen vielen Dank
Deutschland
mit dem President diakollix
butchers in der Ukraine sprechen
wir nicht über abstrakte Berichte
wir sprechen Kinder
Frauen und Männer
deren Schmerz
Russia deswegen
Krieg den sie nicht gewinnen werden
wenden sie im kriegsmutter
Stop sending
lassen sie dir keine nicht länger leiden
schicken sie ihre eigenen Bürger nicht
mehr mit dem Tod
[Musik]
hören sie mit ihren wegwerfen auf die
genauso illegal sind wie die Gesetze die
für sie benutzt werden stoppen Sie den
getreidekrieg der gerade den globalen
Süden in den Hunger treibt und hören Sie
auf dieses Organ
manipulieren denn sicherheitsratefeind
Nationen
für viele von ihnen vier und für einige
in der Generalversammlung
erscheint dieser Krieg vielleicht wie
ein regionalkrieg weit weg zumindest in
Februar 2022 denn in vielen Teilen der
Welt gibt es bereits sehr viel Leid
wegen Konflikten wegen der
Klimakatastrophe wegen der Pandemie und
wegen des Hungers
in Deutschland haben das verstanden aber
ich glaube dass wir
und heute im Sicherheitsrat aber auch in
der Generalversammlung
zusammenfüllen das
was in den letzten 200 80 Tagen passiert
ist niemanden auf der ganzen Welt
unberührt lassen kann
über 200 Tagen brutalen Krieg in der
Ukraine hat der lässt sein Kündigung von
präsent Putin ohne jeden Zweifel gezeigt
russland hat keine sogenannte
militärischer so eine Operation das
heißt ein
Aggressionskrieg mit Kriegsverbrechern
Morden Vergewaltigungen
die Armut der Unsicherheit in der Welt
ich glaube
das ist ein klares Zeichen davon
dass der russischen nur für seine eigene
Rede
reingekommen ist dann eine Weile
gesprochen hat
aber den Hunger die Armut die Ergebnisse
weltweit nicht angesprochen hat
den Straßen von Moskau gibt es keine
Schlangen von Freiwilligen die
zum Krieg in dir keine wollen
stattdessen sehen wir mutige Männer
Frauen und sogar Kinder die auf die
Straße gehen
ein Teil dieses Kriegs gegen die Ukraine
sein wollen
weil sie nicht Teil der 100 hungerkriege
sein wollen diese Männer und Frauen
fühlen was wir alle fühlen
egal
Western kommen das alles was dieser
Krieg bringt Schmerz tot und Zerstörung
ist
also fragen
wenn wir einen einständiges Mitglied das
sollen sich jetzt Rates so einen
Aggressionskrieg gegen seinen Nachbar
führen lassen was bedeutet das für die
Feinden Nationen für eine Institution
deren Kater besagt dass ich zitiere alle
Mitglieder
keine Gewalt gegen die territorale
Integrität oder politisch Unabhängigkeit
anderer Staaten suchen dürfen und ich
hatte irgendwas bedeutet müssen wir und
dürfen wir nicht einfach datenlos
zusehen
nicht trotz sondern gerade
weil ein Mitglied seine werterrechte im
Sicherheitsrat missbraucht
wir müssen den Geist der Unikate
aufrecht erhalten so wie es von der UN
und unseren türkischen Baden gemacht
wurde die den Getreide Deal eingefädelt
haben
und das Weltbild
nahrungsprogramm das auch von
Deutschland unterstützt wird und das
Getreide nach jedem und an den von
Afrika liefert zweiten Nationen und dass
er Strafgerichtshof weiterhin Beweise
sammeln damit
Verbrecher in diesem Krieg zu
rechtschaffen werden
hey there is working to prevention
die daran arbeitet eine Katastrophe
haben sie Berisha nuklear Kraftwerk zu
verhindern und Gespräch mit allen
Parteien führt
wie in contrast
der russische Präsident nicht macht denn
wir sind die Vereinten Nationen vom
Norden nach Süden Osten nach Westen egal
wie klein oder wie groß vielen Dank
Madame Präsidentin
ich danke ihrer Exzellenz Frau beerburg
für diesen Vortrag nun hat das Wort
der Außenminister Polens bin hier Frau
danke Frau Präsidentin
Liebe Ministerkollegen
der Hauptgrund für die heutige
Versammlung ist die Entscheidung
Russlands
ein Nachbarn anzugreifen einen anderen
Mitgliedstaat der Vereinten Nationen
Russland ist ständiges Mitglied des
Sicherheitsrats
ist verantwortlich für den Weltfrieden
und die international Sicherheit
[Musik]
hat Russland beschlossen die
grundlegenden Prinzipien unserer
Weltordnung zu verletzen
der Überfall
ist erfolgt unter völliger Missachtung
des humanitären Völkerrechts und des
internationalen Menschenrechts
die russischen Truppen haben
schreckliche Verbrechen begangen
Hinrichtungen von Zivilisten
Verschwinden von Personen unter Zwang
sexuelle Gewalt
selbst an Kindern sind Beispiele dafür
der militärische Widerstand der Ukraine
ist nicht gebrochen worden deshalb hat
Russland ein versteckten Terror gegen
Zivilisten begonnen als Taktik in diesem
Krieg
jeder Tag bringt neue Belege neue
Aussagen
für russische Verbrechen in den
besetzten Gebieten
und schockiert das
es werden volkerzentren entdeckt
Massengräber mit Leichen die
Folterspuren zeigen die die ganze
Brutalität in dem befreiten Issum
deutlich gemacht haben
ich jung könnte ein weiteres Symbol
dafür werden welche barbarischen
Methoden Russland anwendet
vor diesem Hintergrund tritt Polen
weiterhin für die uneingeschränkte
Rechenschaft ein und für die
Entschädigung für alle angerichteten
Schäden wir unterstützen die
Ermittlungen der ukrainischen
Staatsanwaltschaften
andere Staaten haben das ebenfalls
befürwortet und wir arbeiten auch eng
zusammen mit dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof
[Musik]
wir haben auch eine Gruppe der uecd
Mitgliedstaaten zusammengebracht
die sich zweimal auf den OCD Moskau
Mechanismus berufen haben wir
unterstützen die Arbeiten des
menschenrechtsrats der Vereinten
Nationen in Bereich von Ermittlungen und
wir haben auch im Inland
strafrechtlicher Ermittlungen begonnen
zu dem russischen Angriffskrieg das ist
eine Straftat die nach polnischem Recht
geahndet werden muss
schließlich hat Polen dazu beigetragen
ein
Ermittlungsteam aufzubauen das mit
der internationalen Organisation für
Justiz Kooperation zusammenarbeitet um
Belege für die begangenen Verbrechen
vorzulegen
wir müssen verschiedene Initiativen
berücksichtigen die in Kiew gestartet
wurden
zum Beispiel das sondertributal für
Aggression gegen die Ukraine und der
internationale Mechanismus
für die Entschädigung bei von Russland
der vorgerufenen Schäden
ich möchte an dieser Stelle die
Solidarität Polens mit dem Volk der
Ukraine bekräftigen das ein ganz
bemerkenswerten Mut große
Entschlossenheit und Widerstandskraft
gezeigt hat
eingetreten für die Unabhängigkeit ihres
Landes haben dies tapfer und
entschlossen getan
und jetzt sind wir an der Reihe wir
müssen unser heben und dafür eintreten
dass etwas geschieht das uns alles
schützt wir müssen Russland zur
Rechenschaft ziehen für den Überfall für
die Invasion und alle Verbrechen die im
Laufe dieser Aggression begangen worden
sind danke Frau Präsident
und jetzt darf ich seine Exzellenz Herrn
gabrielos Landsberg ist den
Außenminister von Litauen das Wort
erteilen
wir haben das Wort frau Präsidentin
für
Lettland und auch Litauen
wir uns heute treffen ist weil das
ständige Mitglied des Sicherheitsrats
der Vereinten Nationen
die Grundsätze der Kater der Vereinten
Nationen verletzt wir haben jetzt
Russland bringt tot über die Ukraine und
fordert die Vereinten Nationen heraus
durch Brutalität
und Genozid das ist der Moment in dem
die internationale Völkergemeinschaft
sich nicht abwenden darauf gestern
wurden wir wieder einmal geweckt durch
einen weiteren Versuch Punkt zu
eskalieren er hat jetzt den Kampf gegen
seine eigenes Volk eröffnet und
er wird
versucht sein eigenes Volk zu kolonial
Waffe zu machen
werden keine Angst haben wir werden
Putins
Skrupellosigkeit mit Entschlossenheit
entgegentreten und es ist jetzt auch
notwendig dass Sie internationalen
Organisationen alle Ressourcen nutzen
Russland jetzt auch zur Rechenschaft zu
ziehen und vor den internationalen
strafgerichtsgerichtshof zu bringen
insbesondere Putin muss zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden für die Verbrechen
Russlands gegen die Ukraine das heißt
die internationale Völkergemeinschaft
wird Aufstehen für die Gerechtigkeit und
wir stehen für die Werte und der Frieden
und die Gerechtigkeit werden Segen frau
Präsidentin Russlands Krieg gegen die
Ukraine hat große Konsequenzen weit über
die Ukraine hinaus die Ukraine ist einer
der größten Exporteure für Öl und
Getreide und wir müssen ganz klar sagen
der Mangel an Nahrungsmitteln den Russen
ist den Russen zu verdanken nicht
aufgrund und nicht zurückzuführen auf
die internationalen Sanktionen das heißt
das Moskau Regime hat jetzt weil das
nicht ausreichte den noch einmal mit der
Atomwaffen gedroht und wir alle wissen
dass die Konsequenzen insbesondere in
saporizia schlimmer sein werden als in
Tschernobyl wir werden sämtliche
machtnutzen der internationalen
Völkergemeinschaft das die Russen
aufzufordern dass sie ihre Truppen
bedingungslos zurückziehen aus saporigia
aus dem Atomkraftwerk und wenn wir über
die Ukraine sprechen dann sprechen wir
über waren Mut und Widerstandsfähigkeit
und die Ukraine kämpft für alle
Grundsätze der internationalen
Völkergemeinschaft die Ukraine kämpft
für uns und ich fordere diesen Rat auf
hier nicht gleichgültig der
Angelegenheit gegenüber zu stehen
sondern zu sehen dass wir die Chance
haben jetzt den Frieden und die
Sicherheit weiter zu gewährleisten der
Grundlage der internationalen Ordnung
ganz wichtig ist
Rechenschaft dass wir Russen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden müssen wir
haben jetzt die Chance zu entscheiden in
welcher Welt wir morgen aufwachen wollen
und bevor ich gehe möchte ich noch
einmal daran erinnern dass das nicht nur
Russland das zu Rechenschaft gezogen
werden muss sondern auch Belarus Slava
Ukraine herzlichen Dank
ich bedanke mich bei Herr Landsberg ist
und jetzt hat Wladimir makei das Wort
Außenminister von Belarus
eine große Tragödie für das Land selbst
und für alle die die Schmerzen und
Entbehrungen
erlebt haben die mit jedem Kriegern
hergehen Belarus weiß wegen seiner
Geschichte sehr gut was Krieg bedeutet
für Menschen der einen gönnen sieht
erlebt haben für ein Land das im Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg ein Drittel seinen
Bevölkerung verloren hat und die
Geschehnisse finden in unserer
Nachbarschaft statt wir sind überzeugt
dass nur durch Diplomatie durch
Verhandlungen und mit gemeinsamen
Verständnis ein konfliktleres werden
kann das Geld auch für diesen Konflikt
die Ereignisse an der Ukraine sind nicht
auf einmal geschehen sind eine Ergebnis
von systematischem Ignorieren der
Sicherheitsprobleme in der Region durch
westliche Länder
und weil sie die Besorgnisse der Region
nicht ernst genommen haben über viele
Jahren und ein massiver sanktionsdruck
durch den Westen
Konsequenzen und geführt die ein
vernichten Effekt auf die Region gehabt
haben und der ist am Zonen haben den
Spielraum für meros stark reduziert
werus hat oft gewarnt
dass er seine eskalationsgefallende
Region gibt und eine
Bedrohung
die die Sicherheitsstruktur gefährden
würde die über viele Jahre aufgebaut
wurde wir wollten leider nicht gehört
und wir sehen in der Ukraine dastarische
Ergebnis dieser konnten Position wir
haben immer gesagt man kann nicht in
Garantie eines Staates garantieren indem
man die Sicherheit eines anderen Staates
unterdrückt niemand hat das ernst
genommen und nun ernten wir die
Ergebnisse Belarus machte und macht
alles Mögliche um den Krieg zu wenden
und die regionale und internationale
Sicherheit zu verbessern ich gebe Ihnen
einige Beispiele
[Musik]
2014/152 die den Krieg des Konflikt in
der Ukraine
und auch wenn einige das Bestreiten
haben
Zeit die Intensität der Kämpfe erheblich
reduziert zwischen 2014 und 19 haben wir
den Verein 120 Treffen der Trilateralen
Kontaktgruppe haben gehalten um die
Situation in der Ukraine zu lösen wir
haben mit allen Interessierten Ländern
gesprochen inklusive an unserer
europäischen Partner und konkrete
Schritte vorgeschlagen worden Frieden
und Sicherheit vielleicht wissen Leute
das nicht aber in 2014 während des Mai
dann hat der damalige Premierminister
Polenz
angerufen und gefragt was lässt ich tun
um die Spannungen in Europa zu
reduzieren und Herr Lukaschenko hat dann
mich nach Warschau geschickt mit
konkreten Vorschlägen die interessiert
aufgenommen wurden und man hat jetzt
gesagt
dass er mit präsent Holland und
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel sprechen wird und
dann von zurückkommt seitdem haben wir
nichts darüber gehört und das gab
anscheinend nicht genügend Mut und
zusammenzuarbeiten aber das ist derzeit
sanktioniert war dieses Jahr gab es drei
Runden von friedensparungen in Belarus
und das
Ergebnis dieser Verhandlungen haben alle
Teilnehmer
erklärt dass das Fortschritte gäbe
dabei den Kontakt zu beenden leider
gehört Familien an haben wir unsere
ukrainischen Kollegen vorgeschlagen
direkte Kontakte mit der russischen
Seite aufzubauen unser Vorschläge wurden
aber ignoriert ich weiß nicht warum aber
selbst lange vor der militärischen
sonderoperation durch Russland noch im
Dezember 2008 21 haben
polnische
bedienungsvertreter gesagt dass Belarus
ein feindliches Land ist obwohl wir
Nachbar waren wir gute Handelsmissionen
hatten und hier nie irgendwelche
Probleme mit und der Ukraine hatten seit
März 2022 hätten wir daraus ein
Möglichkeit für Menschen geschaffen die
aus der Ukraine Floren Lisa los nach
Belarus zu kommen seit Februar diesen
Jahres hat Belarus 50.000 ukrainische
Staatsbürger aufgenommen und seit 2014
hat unser Land über 200.000 ukrainische
staatsb aufgenommen
hat
und sie werden ja nicht gezwungen nach
Belarus zu kommen wir einige angedeutet
haben sie kommt freiwillig sie kommen
auch über Polen über die baltischen
Länder und
umrheinischen staatsbekannten Surfen
hat der Präsident im September ein neuen
Erlass
veröffentlicht laut dem
ukrainische Staatsbürger
alle Recht erhalten die
Staatsbürger haben
leider geht der Konflikt weiter die
Kämpfe gehen weiter
und auch die unkontrollierten westlichen
Bemühungen die Ukraine mit Waffen voll
zu
pumpen-nationalistischen
Garten werden gefördert
die NATO konzentriert seine Truppen an
den Grenzen der
Nachbarstaaten einen aggressiver Anti
belarussische Kampagne wurde gestartet
im Bella raus
sein und eine Konfliktpartei haben ganz
klar gesagt
ist nie für den Krieg gewesen wir sind
aber keine Verräter wir haben
Verpflichtungen unseren alliiert
gegenüber
Belarus sagt sehr deutlich dass kein
einziger Bella russischer Soldat und
keine Ausrüstung
in die Ukraine geschickt wurden
unabhängige äußerte Experten haben
bestätigt dass Belarus keine
Kriegspartei ist
was ihr habt auf internationalen Normen
und Gesetzen aller Anschuldigungen gehen
Belarus die Arche gemacht worden vom
Westen sind völlig ein grundlos
daran interessiert an den Fahndungen
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine teils
nehmen über eine strategische
Friedensvereinbarung die die nötigen
Bedingungen schaffen soll für den
Frieden meine Damen und Herren im
maßstärkung der Wahllokalen regionalen
und internationalen Sicherheit sollte
nicht
über eine Erhöhung der militärischen
Kapazität sondern er war einer
motorradlaterale und bilaterale
Mechanismen um
Vertrauen zu stärken nur ein Dialog hin
gegenseitigem Respekt kann
Konflikte in der Region finden und
seine letzte Sache
und alles endet früher oder später am
Verhandlungstisch das ist Fakt und hier
schneller dieser Handlungen Anfang desto
besser es war also überraschend der
Aussage einige Menschen hier zu hören
eine galer die ich hier das wir weiter
kämpfen sollten
diese Aussage wir stehen im Gegensatz
dazu gesunden Menschenverstand danke
das Wort
bitte schön sie haben das Wort
Ministerin ich darf mich herzlich
bedanken bei der französischen
Präsidentschaft des Sicherheitsrates für
die Organisation dieser sehr wichtigen
Sitzung es ist jetzt mehr als sechs
Monate seit dieser illegale sinnlose und
brutale Krieg begonnen hat es wurde ja
schon gesagt hier von vielen heute in
dieser Sitzung das ist ein frontaler
Angriff auf die Karte der Vereinten
Nationen und auf die internationale
Regeln basierte Ordnung es ist ein
angegriff auf die Karte der Vereinten
Nationen wir sollten den internationalen
strafgerichtshofe unterstützen der
gefordert hat Russland muss eine
Invasion sofort beenden und die
Generalversammlung hat mit ein bisschen
Mehrheit
Resolutionen angenommen und Russland
aufgefordert mit seiner Aggression
aufzuhören moralisch und politisch hat
Russland den Krieg schon verloren und
zunehmend verliert es auch auf dem
Schlachtfeld
die Ukraine wird ob Siegen
die gesamte Welt hat die jüngsten
Ankündigungen von Präsident Putin gehört
und seine kleine
scheinreferentin
durchzuführen das ist eine illegale
Annektierung
die wir niemals
anerkennen werden und seine
Mobilisierung von 300.000 Reservisten in
Russland und seine offenen nukleare
Drohung haben wir vernommen das
gefährdet die Welt Sicherheit die Führer
der Welt die sich in dieser Woche in New
York bei den Vereinten Nationen treffen
müssen ein klares Signal aussenden
die Verwendung von
Massenvernichtungswaffen unter keinen
Umständen akzeptabel ist ich bin
ermutigt durch die vielen Äußerungen die
ich heute hier vernommen habe zu dieser
Frage
leider
Putin weiterhin den Weg der Eskalation
aber er wird scheitern er hat in der
Vergangenheit keinen Erfolg gehabt und
in Zukunft wird auch schreibt das ist
bei allen Invasionen und Kriegen der
Fall aber wie viele Frauen Kinder und
Männer müssen denn noch sterben ehe der
russische Präsident
beschließt seine waffenschweigen zu
lassen
das ist mehr als ein Krieg in Europa es
geht um den Schutz von schwächeren
Staaten gegenüber mächtigeren Staaten
wollen wir eine weltweite Rechtsordnung
oder wollen wir das Gesetz des
Dschungels glauben wir an Einfluss
fairen oder an die freie Entscheidung
souveräner starten das ist wirklich eine
Tragödie dieser Krieg und das in
vielerlei Hinsicht neben den
fürchterlich hohen
Opferzahlen und der Zerstörung in der
Ukraine zieht Russland die Welt in eine
wirtschaftliche Rezession und eine
weltweite Nahrungsmittelkrise also
Europäische Union machen wir das was wir
tun können um uns dagegen zu stemmen wir
unterstützen die weltweite
Ernährungssicherheit im Jahre bis zum
Jahr 2024 werden wir mehr als 7,7
Milliarden bereitstellen wir
unterstützen die getreideinitiative
Schwarzes Meer die von der Türkei um
generalsräte anberaumt wurde und das hat
hier schon dazu beigetragen die
Lebensmittelpreise leicht abzusenken
zwei Drittel des Getreides aus der
Ukraine
geht in die Länder die es am
dringendsten bedürfen und nicht in die
europäische Länder heute geht es um
Rechenschaft russische bewaffnete Kräfte
haben die Zivilbevölkerung terrorisiert
und haben unsagbare Verbrechen begangen
Vergewaltigung Tötung alle Opfer
verdienen Gerechtigkeit und Reparation
wir haben die Bilder der Massengräber in
ist jung gesehen nach den Tragödien
Butcher und anderen Orte während
russische Truppen abziehen entdecken wir
wie fürchterlich ihre Besatzung
eigentlich gewesen ist Präsident
selenski hat gestern in der
Generalversammlung gesagt
hat Verbrechen gegeben es muss
Gerechtigkeit warten ansonsten ist ein
Frieden nicht möglich wir werden alles
tun was notwendig ist um die Täter zur
Rechenschaft zu ziehen wir verlassen uns
auf den Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
und die ukrainischen Behörden wir
unterstützen den ICC finanziell und
technisch und unterstützen auch den
ukrainischen
generalstaatsanwalte
auch bei der Zusammentragen von
Beweismittel Frau Präsident
Rechenschaftslegung das ist etwas für
das wir alle verantwortlich sind das
schulden wir nicht nur den
Opfern sondern auch der nächsten
Generation und der Zukunft der Ukraine
denn wenn wir heute gegen die
Straflosigkeit angehen dann ist das ein
Beitrag zu einer sicheren und
gerechteren Zukunft für alle vielen dank
vielen Dank
ganze Herr Josef Borrel von tannenz für
seine Ausführung und ansonsten habe ich
keine Meldungen
und meine Damen und Herren damit sind
wir auch wieder in deutschen Bundestag
für diejenigen Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die bis eben dem un-sicher